Senate Committee on the judiciary's
informational hearing on combating hate
while protecting the Constitution and I
am delighted to see you here my
colleagues thank you very much for
coming
a particulars out out to my Judiciary
staff or putting in a tremendous amount
of time and thought as we work to select
a group to come before us and testify
this is the first of three hearings that
will be taking place at the request of
the President Pro Tem of the Senate in
addressing this very serious but very
important issue and we will be
proceeding I am going to try to keep us
on time there's a hard stop at 12:30 I
have a I have another appointment that
was I was unable to move another
commitment and I think in the next three
and a half hours we should have a robust
but civil and respectful conversation
about an issue that is critically
important particularly to the members of
this committee this year we heard some
legislation and on a unanimous vote
agreed to expand that prefer cement
protections that were at issue in
passing legislation by Assemblymember
Kiley I believe as well as
Assemblymember excuse me by Senator
Nielsen so this committee is very
serious about the First Amendment
sitting on the dais with me are two
other attorneys and mr. Morlock who
knows numbers better than most of us and
so this is an issue that is one of the
great issues of our day particularly in
today's world where we are seeing just
an enormous amount of violence and I
can't help but reflect on the tragedy in
Las Vegas and I know each of us I think
may have had
Institute's who were impacted but
certainly when we see violence like that
we are all impacted and we are all
impacted by the violence that seems to
be emerging in in lieu of discourse in
today's world so again I'm grateful for
all of you for coming and joining us on
the evening of August 11th 2017 as part
of events associated with a unite the
right rally in Charlottesville Virginia
hundreds of avowed neo-nazis and white
supremacist carrying tiki torches march
through the campus of the University of
Virginia where they clashed with counter
protesters the next morning even larger
groups of neo-nazis white supremacist
and counter protesters converged on
Emancipation Park where there was a the
site of a controversy of as to whether
or not to remove a prominent statute of
Confederate General Robert E Lee the
neo-nazis white supremacist and counter
protesters clashed repeatedly in the
streets leading to dozens of injuries
then in the early afternoon a tragedy of
great proportion occurred when a lone
man driving a car ran into a crowd of
counter protesters wounding 19 of them
and killing 130 year-old woman these
tragic events as I mentioned affect us
all and we must address them racism
bigotry homophobia misogyny xenophobia
in short hate undermine our collective
humanity and the fundamental values of
our country run contrary to that level
of hate we propose and believe in this
country that we need to respect one
another regardless of race gender
ethnicity sexual orientation disability
or religion we also believe in this
state and I believe in this nation as
well an opportunity for all if you work
hard you do your best you play by the
rules you should be entitled to be able
to reach that brass ring which is the
promise of America that brought all of
us and our families to this great nation
and
the whole notion of equality under law
Lady Justice if you recall is wearing is
masked with the scales of justice being
equally distributed and we must combat
hate I'm proud that in California our
leadership is fully and unequivocally
committed to a more respectful inclusive
and just society but we are fooling
ourselves if we think that California is
immune from hate what took place in
Charlottesville could and did in fact
happen similarly here right here at the
Capitol in June of 2016 we must be smart
and we must be vigilant in addressing
the challenges associated with
protecting our Constitution while
combating hate and we are committed as I
mentioned earlier this committee has on
a seven to zero vote supported the
principles of freedom of expression for
all and as we will discuss today and
though it can be difficult to accept
that includes the right of people to
express hatred openly and publicly our
topic today is how to uphold these two
commitments at once how do we combat
hate while we protect the constitutional
right to free expression I believe there
are two things that are clear here first
messages of intolerance do real harm and
substantial harm to all of us and to our
effort to move forward as a better more
inclusive society this harm Falls most
heavily upon the shoulders of the
individuals and communities that are
singled out as the target of hatred
failure to acknowledge the seriousness
and legitimacy of this harm failure to
condemn hate speech or worse yet to mock
the serious and legitimate pains of
those who are targeted by hate speech is
nearly as despicable as the intolerance
itself and second resort to violence or
disruption in response to speech even if
it is perceived as hate speech is
illegal and
acceptable groups such as the so-called
auntie feh who have engaged in this type
of violence and disruption of speech
need to stop but these fundamental
points which I suspect the members I
know the members of this committee
unanimously share are still recognizing
that there are many questions that are
still left unanswered and we are honored
and grateful to have expert and
experienced witnesses here to take us
into a deep dive on this topic
our agenda though is quite full our time
is limited to ensure we can fully hear
from everyone I'm going to ask all our
witnesses to stick carefully please to
the time frames that were given to you
and I commit to being gentle but firm
and enforcing those time limits there
will be time for public comment after
all witnesses have presented and
everyone who wishes to do so will have 2
minutes to express their views and ideas
the goal is to finish up by 12:30 and
but we will give everybody their two
minutes if you don't complete your
comments whether you're the speakers or
the public everyone is invited as always
to submit written comments to the
committee for inclusion in the hearing
record now our goal today is not only to
emerge better informed but to look for
additional ways that the legislature can
help ensure that all Californians feel
welcome safe and respected while
upholding the upholding the
constitutional rights of all of us so I
look forward to a robust and civil and
respectful discussion and again I thank
you all for being here I thank the
members of the committee for being here
this is a very important topic and as a
legislative body I look forward to us
demonstrating how we can have a robust
but civil conversation on this very very
important topic with that I look I would
ask my colleagues if anyone would like
on the dies here to make brief remarks
before we begin Senator Monning and
Senator Moreland
thank you madam chair I just wanted to
lead off thinking the chair and your
staff for organizing this all the
witnesses who have come today to to
participate in this I'm curious to learn
of thoughts and recommendations of how
we find this precious balance between
protecting free speech and protecting
people from being victimized by those
who don't respect their rights so thank
you for your leadership madam chair
looking forward to today's proceedings
thank you very much appreciate that
senator more luck thank you madam chair
and thank you for holding a hearing on
combating hate I am certainly a voted
forward spoke for the resolution that
opposed neo Nazism and all the other
stuff that we were facing and stood up
on the floor and recounted a story just
from my own families historical
background my folks survived Nazi
occupation in the Netherlands and so
that is something I grew up with so I
certainly oppose neo Nazism and a high
regard for that Holland is sort of known
as a nation of Tolerance we were just a
very tolerant country and I have a
libertarian streak somehow and so I
appreciate that people have opinions and
have positions and and then I just give
them their space I opposed prop 60 for
the marijuana initiative but I'm sure I
attended every hearing for governance
and finance on how to implement this new
strategy for the state of California
with chair Michael McGuire senator
McGuire I was there every minute to help
him out just as I'm with you every
minute of the committees to you know
even though I don't want to help my kids
or my friends to smoke marijuana that I
still respect their right to do that I'm
not gonna stop people from doing
inappropriate things but I I think
perceived intolerance does not always
mean that it's hate speech sometimes
someone can be telling the truth and you
may not realize it's the truth I have
gone through that experience
when I try to tell individuals the
public in Orange County that it was
going to go in for a very difficult
financial experience I was I was
vilified I had City Council members in
my face saying how come you're going
after the goose that's laying these
golden eggs so so sometimes just telling
the truth is not necessarily hate speech
so I think we need to be careful I think
after reviewing all your documents madam
chair we need to allow people to hold
differing views in positions but we also
every one of us has to display good
manners which means that if we don't
like what's being said or who's saying
it we don't burn private property or
public property we don't go out in the
streets and cause damage and harm so
somehow madam sure if we can figure out
how to encourage civility that would be
the goal for me in this in this hearing
thank you thank you very much any other
comments senator Anderson very briefly
sir I would like to point out that our
colleague had invited Ben Shapiro to be
here because he I guess he was in the
neighborhood at the time or he's up here
on business and I would just ask that
because he's been outspoken on this
issue he's written a lot that perhaps
there might be an opportunity to fit him
in I know it's a neutral request but it
would be terrific if at some point we
were able to let him slide in it having
him speak under public comment while
it's terrific he's written a lot on this
he's been to Berkeley he's experienced
it firsthand I just I would ask the
chair that if there is time available
that she allows him to do more than a
me-too at the end so but thank you so
much for putting this together thank you
and we've we've previously discussed
this we've got a very packed session I
invite mr. Shapiro who's here to listen
carefully to take in what's being said I
think you'll find that the
testimony here is consistent with the
concerns that have been expressed that
we need to be civil whether we agree or
disagree we've got probably the leading
constitutional lawyer in the country
here to speak for the next half an hour
45 minutes and then answer questions and
I invite mr. Shapiro at the end to
during the public comment period give us
his thoughts and what he would suggest
we do to combat hate while protect the
Constitution that's the context that is
the nature of this particular hearing
and also if he has additional thoughts
to submit those in writings I think that
we'll all be very interested in what he
has to say as we are very interested in
the this very impressive group of
panelists who are going to be speaking
so with that let's go ahead and start I
am very excited to introduce our first
speaker who is not only a longtime
personal friend but I think we are so
lucky to have Dean Chemerinsky here as
our first speaker Dean Chemerinsky is
now the Dean at UC Berkeley Law School
probably the finest or certainly one of
the finest law schools in the nation
and he is certainly one of the leading
constitutional law experts he also is
the author of leading treatises on the
subject as well as numerous other
articles and books and fortuitously he
just published this is hot literally hot
off the press from a couple weeks ago
ironically the subject of a lot of
discussion and particularly an issue
here today a book called free speech on
campus which he co-wrote with Howard
Gilman and I urge each Chancellor of UC
Irvine and I urge everyone to read this
book it is both compelling and
frustrating and fascinating
and I think something that should serve
as a guide for all of us going forward
and we are grateful to have up to an
hour of the Dean's time perhaps half an
hour 45 minutes to talk and then to
answer questions that we might have but
again a hard hours so Dean it's just
always a pleasure to see you and thank
you for coming my great pleasure thank
you so much for the kind introduction
senator Jackson members of the committee
it's truly my great honor and pleasure
to be with you this morning issues of
free speech on campus or as old as
colleges and universities but the
context is different now our mental
image of free speech is largely shaped
by the Free Speech Movement at Berkeley
in the mid 1960s where students wanted
to protest on campus and administrators
often trying to stop it now though we're
talking about something different
often the speakers are individuals often
often off-campus provocateurs like my
Annapolis or Ann Coulter or even the
white supremacists who go to campuses
like the University of Virginia the
responses are often from those off
campus like Ann tithi that's come on to
campuses to commit acts of violence the
campuses then become the places or all
of this occurs there's often enormous
cost to the campus and trying to protect
freedom of speech while also ensuring
the safety of students staff and faculty
when ben shapiro spoke at the university
of california berkeley a few weeks ago
the cost was about $600,000 thankfully
he was able to speak without incident
it's no danger to public safety but the
cost was enormous maya annapolis spoke
we go sunday again there was substantial
cost to the campus and had he gone
through with his free speech week the
cost we've been over a million dollars I
applaud Chancellor Carol crest the
Berkeley Police the campus police for
successfully protecting free speech
while safeguarding Public Safety but it
does raise enormous ly important long
term issues so I'm delighted that this
committee is examining them the problem
of hate on
campus and how to ensure freedom of
speech I want to do everything I can to
help your committee I thought what I
might be most useful doing is quickly
summarizing the law for you and then
offering you a few thoughts but you is
the California Senate might do let me
summarize the current law in five points
I realized it's probably already
familiar to you but what I've realized
participating in discussions on the
Berkeley campus over the last several
months is it's very important to
separate our discussions of what the law
is the law should be we can talk here
about what the law is and what governs
the campus but we could have a separate
discussion of how we think the Supreme
Court should change First Amendment law
but those are two quite different
discussions so five quick points for you
and then I'm delighted to take your
questions first it's important to
remember that the First Amendment
applies only to public colleges and
universities in the state is to private
colleges and universities for speech is
protected by a California statute the
Leonard dal it is basic the
constitutional law that the
Constitution's protections of liberty
and equality apply just to the
government private institutions never
have to comply the Constitution this is
one of the least understood the most
important principles of constitutional
law about a week ago when there's a
controversy over football players
kneeling during the national anthem got
a call from a reporter from a major
newspaper saying would it violate the
First Amendment if the NFL were the
teams then fired the players and I said
the First Amendment doesn't apply to the
NFL where the players and the reporters
said to me professor are you sure about
that the answer is yes the First
Amendment applies only to public college
universities but this legislature many
years ago passed what is known as the
Lennard act that says that private
schools cannot punish speech that would
be protected by the First Amendment in
public colleges universities
of course this legislature could revisit
the Leonard bill and revise it but it
means that for all practical purposes
speech cannot be punished in a private
school any more than a public school it
would violate the First Amendment
also of course private schools in the
state are committed to academic freedom
it's reflected in their faculty and
student handbooks many courts have said
these faculty and student handbooks are
contracts between the University and the
faculty and students and are enforceable
in that way as well the second principle
that I identify is that all ideas in
views can be expressed on a college
campus period a campus never can
prohibit or punish speech on the ground
that the idea the viewpoint is false or
even offensive the United States Supreme
Court has sat on so many occasions that
the very core of the First Amendment is
that the government never can punish
censor deny benefits to speech because
of the viewpoint expressed I speak to
you today not only as somebody who's
taught and written about First Amendment
speech for a long time but also it's a
campus administrator and I feel very
strongly as to my law school in my
campus that all views conservative and
liberal those that reflect things that I
believe in and things that I detest
should be able to be expressed I've
recently an occasion to put this into
practice
last Thursday morning the Jewish law
students at Berkeley law school got in
touch with me the Harvard Law Professor
Alan Dershowitz wanted to speak on
campus but there was difficulty in
finding a room I immediately called
professional Dershowitz and said you of
course welcome to speak Berkeley law
school anytime here's my cellphone I
office phone my home phone number my
email we got in touch with each other
he's coming to speak next week now I
disagree with professor Dershowitz but
many things but I believe that he and
those of all views must be welcome on
campus this is about
first amendment in the exchange of ideas
it's also about academic freedom if a
university is going to be a place where
ideas are advanced it must be that all
ideas in views can be expressed period
and the Supreme Court has made it clear
that never can speech you censored or
punished because offensive even deeply
offensive that's the most important case
here to remember is one from less than a
decade ago snyder versus phelps involves
a small church out of Topeka Kansas the
Westboro Baptist Church they regularly
go to funerals where those who died in
military service and using them as the
occasion for expressing a very vile
anti-gay anti-lesbian message they went
to Maryland to the funeral of matthew
snyder a marine who had died in iraq
before the funeral they asked an officer
where they could speak the officer
pointed in area about a thousand feet
away from the funeral occur before the
service they chanted and sang during at
the held of signs that night Matthew's
father Albert saw on the news footage we
could read the signs he was deeply
offended he sued in a jury awarded him
ten million dollars in damages for
intentional infliction of emotional
stress an invasion of privacy but the
Supreme Court eight to one ruled in
favor of the members of the Westboro
Baptist Church Chief Justice Roberts
wrote for the court made clear that the
government cannot punish speech or hold
speech libel on the grounds that it's
offensive all ideas interviews must be
welcomed on college campuses
death P was the First Amendment I
figures the Leonard bill is because the
academic freedom my third point is to
remember that freedom of speech is not
absolute there are exceptions where the
government can censor or punish speech
we're all familiar with the famous words
of justice Oliver Wendell Holmes in the
case of shank verse the United States in
1919 we said there's no right to falsely
shot fire in a crowded theater the
Supreme Court has said that there are
some categories of speech that are not
protected by the First
amendment child pornography being an
obvious example false and deceptive
advertising is another example there are
some categories of unprotected speech
that are very relevant to the topic of
today I'm sure to this committee
one is incitement of illegal activity
the Supreme Court for almost a century
has been clear that speech that
constitutes incitement can be prohibited
and punished but the Supreme Court has
been restrictive in terms of what
constitutes speech that meets the test
for incitement the key case here was
Brandenburg versus Ohio in 1969 thinner
the Supreme Court said in order to
constitute incitement there must be a
substantial likelihood of imminent
illegal activity and the speech must be
directed at causing imminent illegal
activity the fact that a controversial
speaker comes onto campus and some react
against him or her does not constitute
incitement it must be that the speaker
is intending to cause even illegal
activity and there's a statue likelihood
of occurring a second category of
unprotected speech that might be
relevant for you is so-called true
threats are not protected by the First
Amendment the initial case here was
United States versus Watts which is a
federal law that makes it a crime to
threaten the President of the United
States the Supreme Court said I'm
quoting its words true threats are not
protect for the First Amendment but this
has to be distinguished from hyperbole
the Supreme Court has reaffirmed that
true threats are not protected but has
never clearly defined what's enough to
be a true threat there's actually a
split among the federal courts of
appeals on the definition of true threat
I think the best approach is to say that
the true threat is speech that
reasonably cause a person to imminently
fear for his or her physical safety
there should be no First Amendment right
to cause a person to reasonably fear
for imminent danger to his or her
personal safety so if an angry group of
students surround another student and
yell at the student make the student
fear imminently for physical safety
that's not speech protected by the First
Amendment final category that I'd
mentioned his speech does not protect
for the First Amendment is harassment
there's now a well-established body of
law in the workplace context that says
that harassing speech is not speech that
safeguarded by the First Amendment
I think the most obvious example if an
employer says to an employee speak with
sleep with me or you are fired that
would not be protected by the First
Amendment even though it was only words
in the employment context the Supreme
Court has been clear that speech that
amounts to creating a hostile timid
ating environment on the basis of race
or on the basis of sex can be the basis
for a lawsuit for employment
discrimination title six of the 1964
Civil Rights Act says that institutions
that receive federal funds cannot
describe a certain race tunnel 9 says
the tutions education through syphilis
cannot discriminate on basis of sex many
courts have said that harassment
violates title six in total 9 was based
on race or gender and so speech that
rises to the level of harassment can be
punished but here it's important to
distinguish between the use of the word
harassment in a colloquial sense and
harassment in a legal sense the fact
that their speech on campus that of sad
students does not constitute harassment
harassment generally has to be directed
at a person or at least has to be
pervasive it is interfering with
educational opportunities of a surveys
sex religion or sexual orientation to
pick a vivid example there was an
incident at the University of California
San Diego where a noose was put over a
tree is a vile symbol of hate but that
does not constitute harassment even
though be upsetting but if someone
a news to the dormitory door of an
african-american student that would
constitute harassment now you'll notice
as I mentioned these categories of
unprotected speech what I didn't mention
and that's the focus of your hearing
today
that's hate speech the Supreme Court has
been clear that speech even when it's
hateful is protected by the First
Amendment
there is no categorical exception for
speech on the ground that it's hateful
as I say this I recognize that hate
speech causes great harm it causes great
psychic harm to those subjected to it it
interferes with educational
opportunities students and it fears with
the work of faculty and staff and yet
the law is clear as I said that hate
speech is protected by the First
Amendment as examples you might remember
the case of Rav versus city of Saint
Paul from 1992 and involved the st. Paul
ordinance that prohibited burning a
cross or painting a swastika and a
matter likely to anger alarm or caused
resentment the Supreme Court unanimously
declared that law unconstitutional or
you might remember the case Virginia
versus black from 2003 and involved the
Virginia law that prohibited cross
burning files symbol of hate the Supreme
Court eight-to-one declared that
unconstitutional in the early 1990s over
350 colleges and universities including
some in California adopted so-called
hate speech codes every one to be
considered by a court was declared
unconstitutional why is this well some
of it is the impossibility of trying to
define hate speech in a way that's not
unconstitutionally vague and overbroad
the last two years at the University of
California Irvine I co-taught a class on
free speech on campus with Chancellor
Howard Gilman and as an exercise we
asked our students to try to define hate
speech to write it up as a code or a
statute and they saw how impossible it
is to do I mean it's not vague or unduly
over broad some of the reasons why I
think courts
allowed hate speech codes is the
experience under them and the experience
with hate speech laws in foreign
countries what we've seen is almost
always there used against the very
groups that we intend to protect the
University of Michigan adapted a hate
speech code after a series of horrible
incidents every attempt to enforce it
every complaint was brought against
minority students
when England adopted its law prohibiting
hate speech the first prosecution was
against the Zionist group on the
argument that Zionism was a form of
racism but perhaps most of all the
reason hate speech is protect it goes
back toward I said a moment ago all
ideas all views are protected even an
offensive Justice John Marshall Harlan
said that to censor words is to censor
ideas we can't cleanse the English
language without please the most
squeamish among us as I try to tell my
students the only way that our free
speech can be protected tomorrow is to
safeguard the speech that we don't like
today whereas the Supreme Court said in
June of 2017
we don't need free speech for the speech
we like we'd let that go on anyway
we need free speech for the speech that
we detest the fourth principle that I'd
identify for you is that time place and
manner restrictions are permissible so
long as they leave adequate alternative
places for communication even when
there's a First Amendment right to speak
it doesn't mean that there's a right to
speak at any time at any place in any
manner there's right to speak in Los
Angeles because there's no right to go
down the middle of the 110 freeway in
rush hour and use that as the place for
speech let me focus on college campuses
campuses can have time place and manner
restrictions with regard to speech
disruption of school activities so as to
protect public safety I mentioned a
moment ago that I've invited Alan
Dershowitz to speak next week what we're
looking for is a classroom
it's not being used at the time that he
wants to address the students he can't
insist no speaker can that we cancel
classes in order to accommodate the
ability to speak disrupted school
activities there's a right to speak on
campus but nobody has a right to come in
my classroom and shout so that I can't
teach those right to speak here in
Sacramento but nobody has a right to
come into your chambers and speak so you
can't hold your business likewise
campuses can and must use time place and
manner restrictions so as to be able to
Public Safety there as I've spoken to
administrators at the University of
Berkeley I strongly encourage them to
have controversial speakers in
auditoriums rather than open areas of
campus that way there can be tickets
metal detectors secure the perimeter so
as to be able to have them speak while
still securing public safety that's of
course exactly what happened when ben
shapiro spoke a few weeks ago he's
allowed to speak in the largest
auditorium on campus but they were able
to create a perimeter to ensure his and
everyone's safety while still allowing
the speech that's important as you think
about time place and manner restriction
to keep in mind they must always be
viewpoint neutral they can never be
based on the message that's expressed it
must always be adequate alternative
places for communication it wouldn't be
okay for a college campus to say go ten
miles away and have your speech it is
okay to say that you can't speak outside
of a classroom building when classes are
in session or come back another time of
this day or use a different room the
time place and manner restrictions have
to be reasonable they also have to be
viewpoint neutral week one of the
hardest issues right now for college
campuses is how much money do they have
to spend in order to ensure freedom of
speech while protecting public safety I
was asked this question by the
Chancellor at UC Berkeley Carol crest
and I said there's no clear law on point
here I mentioned the tremendous cost to
Berkeley and protecting the ability of
mr. Shapiro
mr. Ian appleís and others to speak but
is there a point at which the campus can
say we can't afford to be able to
protect public safety while still
allowing speech therefore we have to
cancel the speaker the campus has the
legal as well as the ethical duty to
ensure the safety of its students staff
and faculty what you can't do so at a
reasonable cost what if for example not
for a week but every week in a semester
there was going to be free speech events
that cost over a million dollars the
best answer that I could give to
Chancellor Crist in the best I didn't
give to you here is that the campus must
spend a reasonable amount to ensure
Public Safety it cannot impose costs on
speakers or student groups that prevent
the speech from occurring but this is a
place where the law simply has not
developed my fifth in a final point is
that campus officials have important
tools regard to dealing with free speech
on campus while also ensuring an
inclusive learning environment I think
it is the obligation of campuses not
only to protect free speech but make
sure that there is an inclusive learning
environment for all students one of the
most important tools that campus
officials have is their right to free
speech
it was also justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes who said that the best remedy for
the speech that we don't like is more
speech and I have seen on many occasions
campus officials using their right to
more speech as a counter to hate on
campus there's an incident many years
ago when I was a professor at the
University of Southern California when
somebody wrote a very vile anti-gay
epithet on a board rather than try to
figure out who wrote it and punished the
student - then Dean the law school Scott
vice put a letter and every student and
faculty mailbox that tells you how long
ago it was condemning the hate speech
and talking about how important it is
that would be a community that's
inclusive of all last year I participate
in a program put on by the Office of
Civil Rights the Department of Education
Council of the University of Mississippi
talk about effective the campus has been
in responding to hateful incidents with
more speech campuses must also engage in
educational programs for their students
we've all heard the phrase
microaggressions speech that inflicts
injury often unintentionally I think
it's important that campuses educate
students about the kind of speech that's
hurtful to others they shouldn't punish
the speech we all learn from a young age
there's certain things that we shouldn't
say in public or the hurtful to others
students need to be aware of this an
education is important campuses need to
look for ways provide safe spaces for
all the students so long does that come
about
there's sensitive speech I think one of
the hardest challenges of campus in this
regard again I think it's a matter for
this committee in this legislature is
how to deal with the medium of internet
when it comes to the speech the Internet
may be the most profound tool for free
speech since the development of the
printing press
it democratizes for everyone the ability
to reach a mass audience it used to be
to reach a mass audience you need be
rich enough to own a newspaper or get a
broadcast license now anyone with a
smartphone even access to a modem in a
library can reach a mass audience it
gives us all tremendous access to
information but just a speech can always
beneficial so can it be harmful the
internet now provides a tool on campuses
and elsewhere for quickly disclosing
very private information about
individuals to a mass audience and we've
seen that done on campuses to great harm
it allows for the circulation of false
information to a large audience almost
immediate basis it has been a tool for
harassing students unfortunately all too
often women in mordor's students and we
don't have the legal tools to deal with
how the internet is used in this way and
how our campus is going to be able to
deal with this so these are the basic
legal principles that I think have to
guide you and you have to guide campus
officials across the state in the
country Senator Jackson asked me some
thoughts about things that
Legislature might do and that you might
consider one thing that I think is
important to consider what kind of
financial assistance can be provided to
campuses when they're providing the
security to ensure safety and free
speech it is simply not sustainable for
campus like Berkeley to be spending the
large sums of money that are going on
now those are dollars that come away
from the education of students in the
mission of the college universities so I
think since the universities are
performing a public service by
facilitating speech while also ensuring
public safety they need the help from
the legislature when they're absorbing
these costs second I think there can be
additional legislative steps to deal
with hate crimes on campus there is no
First Amendment right to engage in a
hate crime there are already laws that
provide for greater penalties for hate
crimes the United States Supreme Court
and Wisconsin versus Mitchell said that
there can be greater penalties for hate
motivated crimes I think given the
problem of hate crimes on campus the
legislature might want to consider
special legislation specifically the
regard to penalties for hate crimes on
campus and third and finally I would
suggest looking at education one of the
things that is of great concern to me is
the lack of awareness of current college
and university students about the
importance of free speech the history of
free speech and rights of free speech
and I think much more in the way of
civic education is truly essential
likewise we need to develop better
educational programs in combating hate
in encouraging tolerance on campus this
is a particularly difficult time for
college universities as a prolific time
for the entire country when it comes to
speech but I also believe that the
survival of our democracy and this isn't
hyperbole requires that we find the way
to protect free speech while still
combating hate writing public safety so
that's why I so applaud this committee
for this hearing and everything I
possibly can to help you Thank You Dean
very very much appreciate
your your comments we do have about 15
minutes for questions from the Dyess so
we'll start with Senator Monning and and
go from there thank you thank you madam
chair again Dean Chemerinsky thank you
for sharing the knowledge in the
ultimately very complex shades of grey'
in protecting free speech and First
Amendment right in its interpretation in
protecting people from violence etc I
had a few questions one is in a
university setting when you talked about
time place and manner well I understand
there's no distinction in terms of
content of speech can there be any
distinction whether it's a student
organization or students participating
versus non students non faculty
non-staff outside speakers who invite
themselves or who show up on a campus
let me here draw a distinction between
public universities and private
universities for public universities the
answer your question is no public
universities are public property and as
public property it is accessible for
speech that doesn't mean that every
place at all times accessible for speech
but it cannot exclude those from outside
the campus also what usually happens is
student groups or faculty members will
invite the outside speakers and it then
blurs that distinction for private
schools it's different because it is
private property and the ability to use
private property for speech is different
than the ability to use public property
keeping in mind that when it comes to
punishing students faculty or staff
private college universities cannot
punish that which would be speech
protected by the First Amendment thank
you and Berkeley of course is synonymous
with the free speech movement of the 60s
establishing the right for that public
speech
at a public university when I was at
Berkeley late sixties early seventies
there was something called the mall
furred act that allowed the university
to ban people from campus summarily for
up to two weeks without a due process
hearing based on the prospective threat
of disrupting university activities do
you know if that is still the law of the
state of California I don't think so and
I think if it is unconstitutional under
current free speech law it's also unwise
now that doesn't mean that campuses
can't take actions to ensure public
safety they must do so but that kind of
a prior restraint would not be
constitutional they said I think the
Chancellor Carol Chris did a terrific
job of trying to ensure free speech over
the last few weeks while still
protecting public safety thank you and
at the risk of revealing too much I was
the subject of a Mulford act ban based
on anti-war activities that were
peaceful in nature and there was no
right to a due process hearing I was a
tuition paying student who was banned
from my own campus and if I had been a
lawyer then I would have gladly
represented you in challenging that and
we did have a lot of volunteers step up
to help us on that to our present
situation in you provided I think a very
helpful distinction between some of the
exceptions to protected speech that
create an immediate or imminent threat
of violence but in your final comments
about hate speech where does hate speech
cross the line between protected speech
versus speech I think you gave the
example of the noose hanging from a tree
versus the noose hung on a student's
dorm room but for a speaker or an
organization that the focus of its
speech is vilifying a protected class of
people and threatening or calling for
their exclusion from
Society or their protection where does
that hate speech cross the line of not
being printed
when is it protected versus a violation
of what we call hate speech hate speech
is protected speech let me give you a
couple of examples and then answer your
question directly in the late 1970s
early 1980s you might remember the Nazi
Party wanted to march in Skokie Illinois
predominantly Jewish suburb of Chicago
with a large number of Holocaust
survivors Skokie tried to prevent it
directly or charge them a large amount
of money every court to rule declared
the efforts of Skokie unconstitutional
and said that the Nazis had the right to
march in Skokie hate speech is protected
speech or to take a recent example the
events in Charlottesville Virginia that
Senator Jackson mentioned if you read
the signs they're among the most vile
things I've seen and I will quote one
sign directly
it said belong in the oven it felt
to me like a punch in the stomach but
they have the right to say that when
does it become unprotected if it comes
it meets a test for incitement has to be
a substantial likelihood emanating
activity and directed of causing a look
like activity even amounts to a truth
rad causing a person to reasonably fear
for his or her imminent physical safety
or if it amounts to the level of
harassment likely being directed at a
person or at least so pervasive it's
interfering with educational
opportunities there's sunrays sex
religion sexual orientation it would
have to meet one of those tests and we
can certainly talk about those tests and
there's gray areas the application but
it's a general matter whether we like it
or not under current law hate speech is
protected speech but when it does cross
that line it's more often than not gonna
be real-time a speaker says let's get
those people who are here today you know
follow me let's get them inciting
violence calling for violence but that
requires a real-time assessment of
whether that microphone needs to be
unplugged or not the law generally
believes the way we deal with that is
prosecuting and punishing people after
the
that the Supreme Court is also one of
the core principles the first amendment
is we try not to prevent or promote
doesn't allow us to prevent speech and
advancement it's called prior restraints
right and senator I might indicate that
that we're going to have that discussion
we do have panelists who will be
addressing that very specific point
you've just two things just a final
question if I might well on the prior
restraint there was a classic gathering
in Bakersfield California with Bobby
Kennedy in the United Farm Workers when
the sheriff in Kern County was arresting
farm workers before they arrived at a
what was considered to be an illegal
picket line because he knew they were
driving to break the law Bobby Kennedy
encouraged him to read the Constitution
during the lunch break at the hearing my
final question does go to the cost to
the unit of public institutions what if
what if you had a budget that said we
have five million dollars to provide
security for for the free speech rights
of any speaker we've exhausted that five
million dollar budget is it in your
conversation with the Chancellor is that
your view that this is an open checkbook
that to protect free speech if you
exceed that five million dollar
budgetary line are you compelled as a
public institution to to find the money
wherever you can laws unclear here there
simply are not yet cases in terms of how
much does the campus have to do would be
five million would it be ten million but
we also have to think back you mentioned
the anti-war protest what if the campus
said in the 1960s that we can't have the
anti-war protests because they cost us
money in terms of police or in terms of
cleanup we would have said of course
you'd have to spend money but what it
was a Southern University nearly 1960's
saying we can't have the civil rights
protest here because we can't afford the
cost obviously there is a burden in
terms of having to absorb the cost in
order to protect speech but where the
line is drawn how much no one can tell
you that because the cases just haven't
been there yet thank you thank you madam
chair Thank You senator Moorlach we've
got about five minutes
great I'll take 8 good to see you you
won't but my mother said to me that when
you were bullied or you had someone in
your face you know you just you need to
learn to ignore it and and you know if
you ignore this issue then maybe they'll
just die out but here at the capital we
had neo-nazis show up and we had others
show up and it was a fist brawl and I
know we have public safety coming up
later but we're seeing left-wing groups
now more than ever at least I am I just
observing occupy anti anarchist groups
and and so where does where's the
outrage of their display of hate to
react to their perception of hate
violence is always unacceptable it
doesn't matter if it's in the left or
the right
hate is always unacceptable it's the
left or the right so in that sense I and
I hope you and all the members will
express outrage it there should never be
a right to disrupt a speaker by violence
or any other way because otherwise then
there really is no free speech because
we can always silence those who don't
like just by threatening or engaging in
violence against them
thank you I'll yield the rest of my time
thank you so much senator Stern thank
you madam chair and thank you Dean
Chemerinsky for coming out I agree with
the remarks of the chair to start up you
of the chair but the finest legal
institution in the nation as a bold grad
I would have to side with that
assessment I wanted to first just make
an observation I had two quick questions
then one is I actually find it
incredibly fitting that you're here
today with mr. Shapiro I wanted to
applaud both you and him actually as
well as primarily Chancellor Crist
for handling that event with appropriate
security but I mean you're looking at
someone who has actually attracted an
excessive amount of anti-semitic
backlash for their views views which IBM
and
disagree with and would love to invite
mr. Shapiro back up to Sacramento at the
appropriate time to debate the substance
of his views on anything from the
existence of global climate change to
the non-existence of a militant
homosexual agenda in this country but I
think the point here today is that the
substance aside the process matters and
you conducted that process admirably I
did in in that same vein that we talked
a little bit about the sort of analogies
between tort law and constitutional law
in this subject and the notion that the
actual causation or the intent and the
intent to cause or the substantial
likelihood and an intent to cause
violence is sort of that limit within
within speech I wanted you to just deal
specifically with the Charlottesville
incident and explain to us why the
driver who murdered so many people
there's there's not a causal link or
some kind of Nexus where say in the
future if a March were held with those
same intentions say on social media
people were organizing and references
were made to Charlottesville
even potentially applauding it allusions
to it you know how to sort of in advance
without prior restraint draw some of
those lines to prevent acts of what I
think can be fairly argued are domestic
terrorism so how do we how does law
enforcement and how do we sort of draw
that line and and I guess I wanted to
raise this notion of is it about this
intervening sort of actor this
volitional act by that one individual in
Charlottesville it really undermines the
ability to make that that speech
restraint so that was my first question
well can you answer that in about two
minutes because then I actually have two
more to well answer quickly please later
I did this real quick so I get to the
discussions before we run out of time
the law has long long run a distinction
between speech
and action the speakers in Charlotte
some of the white supremacist group were
vile but that's quite different than the
act of driving a car that's an act of
domestic terrorism I don't think any
court would find who's the speakers that
caused that it was to use your was the
volitional act of the driver and they'll
be in the eyes of the law so on that
same note in tort law when even that
intervening volitional actor there's
there's a famous case of a drunk driver
driving a set on a set of Goodyear tires
that the tires themselves are faulty and
that actor may have been drunk while
driving the car but ultimately the
manufacturer for creating faulty tires
is liable but in that same sense of the
victims in other words are not on the
hook that ultimately there is some sort
of you know liability upstream but in
speech we have a campus like UC Berkeley
that is straining itself to make sure
the cost of tuition are affordable make
sure the campuses are vibrant and hiring
top talent and professors and doing a
research and yet we're expending
millions of dollars to sort of do
something that accommodate a speech
activity that they didn't themselves
cause so in terms of how to sort of
architect a broader framework to defray
or assess those costs not necessarily on
the campus but are there any
constitutional limits on assessing say a
broader free speech fee on all of
society that actually benefits from that
activity or any sort of has any
precedent for that kind of sort of
insurance policy or or ability to defray
costs on it I think excuse me I want to
interrupt that it was just pointed out
to be by my staff that actually we have
till 10:15 so you don't have to rush
your answer in my apologies if there are
any other questions my bad please feel
free to go here we have until 10:15
Senate I think you raise a key question
for this moment in time of who should
bear the cost the one place where the
law is clear is you can't force this
speaker to bear the cost in order to be
able to speak you can't say to a
controversial speaker the only way you
can come to campus is if you bury the
security cost because that would then
prevent the person from speaking if a
large security cost but the question
that I think that you as a legislature
face is do you want the individual
campuses to bear this or do you want to
have the taxpayers bear it in some way
so yes obviously be constitutional
should you wish to create some kind of
fun to reimburse campuses for this class
and again to those who say well why
should we have to bear the cost at all I
go back to what I said to Senator
Monning if this was the anti-war
protests this was the early sixties
wouldn't we say of course the campus has
to bear the cost of her speech and then
you can't make choices based on liking
or disliking the particular views and
while I you know it pains me a little
bit for my campus to be expending a
million dollars a week or whatever we
paid to keep mr. Shapiro safe I think we
should ought to bear no expense to keep
anybody safe who wants to come to that
campus and express their their views so
I think it was a smart move and we'll be
exploring that further my very very last
question I'll be brief is this this
notion of cheap speech that professor
Hasson your former colleague at Irvine
and also Eugene Volokh down at UCLA
presciently sort of looked to the future
and saw this year where it's not even
that the speech itself can cut or harm
but that it piles up over time and it's
not the quality of the speech but it's
actually the quantity of in in the case
of the last election we had accumulation
of lies that on the Internet are freely
allowed to be expounded and and actually
shape the democratic institutions that
actually that we rely on to ensure that
this whole speech paradigm can exist so
how do we start to navigate that is it
solely on the private actors to to sort
of police themselves or label or find
other ways to fact-check and sort of
leave it up to the free marketplace or
is it become when you have bots or
entire you know work houses in macedonia
designed to pile up false statements
using social media platforms does it
sort of
becoming a matter of free speech and
actually become a threat to democracy
itself so I refer cephalic from you see
like coined this phrase cheap speech and
my colleague Rick Hanson is written
about it and this really goes to the
point that I was making of how the
Internet has changed speech it does make
it easy for all of us to engage in
speech to a mass audience at very little
cost just take out your smartphone and
if you have Twitter following or the
ability to get on a blog that is wide
readership you can then circulate
something there's benefits to it and I
don't think professor voila confess we
have sent are sufficiently tender the
benefits of democratizing speech in this
way and there are costs to it I think
with you as a committee and a
legislature they notice what are some of
the areas of costs where legislation
might help take the example of public
disclosure of private facts I am very
concerned about the ability over the
internet to reveal very private
information on people to a mass audience
and it has especially come on campuses
as a form of harassment I don't think
the law has kept up with this and it is
something the legislature might consider
in that regard a harassment through the
use of the internet because it's so easy
to do that and there's some very good
writing that's been done Danielle's
citroen professor at university of
maryland has done some of the best
writing on this subject there's just a
conference a couple of weeks ago on this
the university of maryland customized by
the department of justice and so i think
focusing more on harassment over the
internet i think one of the challenges
for in this true of junior high schools
and high schools as well as colleges and
universities is to what extent can they
punish student use of the internet in a
manner that would constitute harassment
of public disclosure of private fact our
traditional model for students speeches
speech that occurs in the school or on
the campus and what can the school
officials do about it what high schools
as well as colleges diversity is now
having to confront this what about
hateful speech that wouldn't be
protected by the First Amendment or
public disclosure of private fact that a
student does using the Internet at home
now
on campus so if you're asking where are
the issues that I think we might need
future legislation I think that would be
some of the examples thank you very much
and adjust that in sort of the follow-up
and then we do have another question
from Senator Moorlach and then senator
Anderson I wonder you know when when
people give speeches at college campuses
and charge huge amounts of money for
example let's say someone gives a speech
and is able to charge a hundred thousand
dollars is there any way that the school
because this isn't this is paid speech
if you will is there any way that the
school could offset some of its costs by
charging the speaker some percentage or
some way to be able to offset it because
the speaker is actually making money
it's a business if you will or it's a
for-profit opportunity to speak with
that is that a line we can draw or not
the answer in two steps first I can only
speak of the schools where I've been
Dean you were scuffling Irvine School of
Law and University of Berkeley school ah
we do not pay honoraria for speakers
when it's an endowed lecture where
there's a fund it's a 2500 honorarium
and expenses for all others it is just
expenses
I cannot justify using my students
tuition to pay speakers to come onto
campus and so at least at the two
schools where I've been Dean the only
honorary we've ever paid is that there's
a separate endowment to support it so
but I don't know I can't speak beyond
that under the campuses the second goes
to the First Amendment where the law is
clear as the government cannot charge a
speaker of fee that would keep the
speaker from being able to appear Skokie
could not charge the Nazi Party or
require in the post an insurance bond
they would interfere with their ability
to speak now campuses can have viewpoint
neutral rules in terms of student groups
invite speakers the student groups have
to bear a reasonable cost and so it's
not that the campus can't recoup some of
the costs but it cannot be a charge
that's so large it would keep the
speaker from being able to appear thank
you thank you thank you all right
senator Morlock had a quick question and
then senator Anderson we've got about
eight more minutes perfect like you want
to call you urban please
sorry you left Orange County but thanks
for your service to the University of
California Irvine growing up the word
hate was foot what I would call a strong
word it's like it's like a word you just
you don't you really shouldn't say I
hate somebody it was just something in
my my growing up that it was just
something you just it was just a very
very strong word but now that we're
discussing this topic and and now we're
looking at well who's really displaying
hate in this country and what's going on
and what's happening on our campuses so
I'm just a little curious about some of
these groups that are making statements
and and one of them is the Southern
Poverty Law Center are you familiar look
what they've done and so they put out a
list of hate groups and it's just like
such a strong label and I'm just
wondering you know I always always tell
people be careful what you hate because
you will become what you hate you you
know you're gonna you can hate something
so much you can hate your dad being an
alcoholic and then you become an
alcoholic I mean just some I don't wanna
get to psychologically but what is this
group trying to do and why does it
benefit and does it just kind of stir up
more frustration than help the problem
no Senator Reid the signs that were held
up by the white supremacist group in
Charlottesville though there may always
be difficulty in defining a word of
precision there's no doubt that those
signs expressed hate as I said when I
saw the sign and I'm quoting verbatim
belong in the oven that is the
expression of hate now we can then talk
about the definition and one of the
problems that the hate speech codes have
had is trying to define hate with any
precision so the University of Michigan
hate speech club that I mentioned
defined hate speech is that which
stigmatizes or demeans
on the basis of race sex religion or
sexual tation and I think that
stigmatize urdhva means is too broad a
definition but I can't say strong enough
the fact that we might have difficulty
in drawing the line as to what hate
doesn't mean
it doesn't exist it clearly does and we
should all condemn the hate speech
whether liberal or conservative democrat
or republican that's why I appreciate
the exercise that you give to your
students along with Howard Gilman to say
okay bu you write the law and I think
you made a great point there and I
appreciate that and thanks for coming
thank you madam chair Thank You senator
Anderson I really appreciate all your
remarks I just dropped by saying that
when I was in college campus I didn't
have a lot of money put into my books
and studies and so whenever a speaker
came on campus I always enjoyed going
and the diversity of speakers I think
helped enlighten me I think the problem
with the internet from my view is too
often we go to websites we like we're
not in the business of going to websites
we don't like and yet we're not exposed
to the whole world and have a broader
view and a better understanding of the
world when we hear from all walks of
life so I think it's really important
that these speakers make it to our
campuses and I was reading earlier this
year that some of the some of the
organizations that hosted some of the
speakers that were protested did pay
extra were expected to pay extra to
offset the costs of the police and then
later I read police may no rest while
the campus was being torn up the
organizations were told that they were
going to be financially liable for
anything that was torn up or any
problems that occurred that allows
groups to to just merely threaten the
protests to keep free speech off the
campus and you had touched upon it but
I'd like for you to go a little deeper
into it because I think this is a really
crucial issue and I also question when
we have free speech on the campus it's
I'm thinking it's for the students and
to have protesters who if you're wearing
a mask how do we even know that you're a
student you know it's one thing to come
in protest if you're there and you're a
student and you protest peacefully but
come with
asks in billy clubs to create havoc is
the worst i mean all it reminds me of is
nazi germany as they were rampaging
through the streets so if you wouldn't
mind addressing there in a little more
detail and there's how we can prevent
that because to lose free speech on our
campuses I think creates more hate than
because I think that when you're exposed
to eight a lot of times you can't
believe that another person would would
say such file things as you described it
in that one poster I can you say let me
break down your question into three
parts first absolutely you're right that
college university have to be places
where speakers of all viewpoints all
ideologies
are present second as I said to senator
Jackson campuses can charge student
groups when they bring speakers on
campus so long as the charges are
viewpoint neutral and so long as it not
interfere with the ability to have the
speakers come onto campus this has long
been true generally on campuses groups
get Student Activity fee money and if
they're gonna bring a speaker on campus
they have to pay for some of the costs
of that speaker but it cannot be a
charge that would be so great is to keep
the speakers from being able to appear
now there's no precise line of how much
you can charge or not charge it's always
going to be a question of can be a
reasonable charge so long as its
viewpoint neutral the third part of your
question went to the ability to speak
with masks or to have billy clubs let me
deal with the latter first there is no
First Amendment right they have a weapon
demonstration on campus people don't
bring billy clubs or guns to engage in
civil discourse whatever discussion we
might have about the Second Amendment
campuses can constitutionally prevent
all weapons on campus it demonstrations
campus can use metal detectors to do
that or anything else that's there masks
are a more difficult question because
there are some lower court cases that
say there's a First Amendment right or
the Supreme Court is that there's a
first timer right to speak anonymously
and some lower courts have said that
includes the right to speak
masks I think in limited circumstances
the city can prevent masks I understand
that Berkeley for planned demonstration
said in light of what had occurred last
January in February they for a limited
time we're going to prevent people from
wearing masks at the demonstration I
think with that kind of a record under
limited circumstances there are cases
that say the right to speak anonymously
includes the right to wear a mask
so that's just the law with regard to it
I hope I addressed your question
question very briefly we've got I think
one more minute okay what about student
IDs insisting on that they have to have
student IDs so that you don't have
hooligans from outside the area coming
in with the sole purpose of dominating
the school the campus can have an event
that's students staff and faculty only
and say you need an ID to get into that
event but a campus can't exclude from
the public areas at all times the public
because it is public property but it
can't have time place and manner
restrictions okay thank you thank you
thank you Dean it's always an honor to
have you here thank you for your
statements and your expertise and your
intellect and your wisdom there's a lot
that we will continue discussing and I
hope that you will continue to be
available to answer any questions we
might have my great honor and pleasure I
can be of help to you and your
colleagues in any way just please let me
know what I can do thank you so much
very much appreciate your being here and
our next speaker is Johanna Mendelssohn
who is a senior investigator with the
anti-defamation league she has devoted
the past 17 years of her career to
evaluating the activity and tactics of
extremist groups and movements training
law enforcement officers and publishing
reports and articles on a wide range of
extremist topics today she has trained
over 12,000 federal state and local law
enforcement officers prosecutors
military personnel judges and
look officials throughout the country
Mendelsohn has or I should say MS
Mendelsohn has testified in numerous
court cases as a subject matter expert
on the white supremacist and sovereign
citizens movements and she will be
addressing in in response to sort of
where the direction and the issues that
have been raised she will be addressing
the history the current status
organizational structure and financing
of white supremacist and other hate
groups here in California and we are
delighted and very much appreciative to
have a half an hour of your time we were
hoping to do maybe 20 minutes of your
presentation and then have about ten
minutes available for questions and as a
reminder we will have public comment
following all the scheduled witnesses
and in the meantime colleagues again
we're trying to keep the ship on time
this train on time and very much
appreciate your being here thank you the
floor is yours yeah shares senator
hannon Beth Jackson senators I am Joanna
Mendelssohn senior investigative
researcher and director of special
projects with the anti-defamation
league's Center on extremism I've been
part of the ADL for 17 years thank you
so much for the opportunity to
participate in today's timely hearing
since the nineteen thirteen the mission
of the anti-defamation league has been
to stop the defamation of the Jewish
people and secure justice and fair
treatment for all for decades the league
has fought against bigotry and
anti-semitism by exposing extremist
groups who spread hate and incite
violence the league is now the foremost
non-governmental authority on domestic
terrorism extremism organized hate
groups and hate crimes through our
Center on extremism whose experts
monitor a variety of extremist and
terrorist movements ADL plays a leading
role in exposing their movements and
activities while helping communities and
government agencies alike in combating
ADL's team of experts uses cutting-edge
technology to track and disrupt
extremists and terrorists worldwide ABL
is the largest non-governmental
organisation providing the United in the
United States for of training for law
enforcement on hate crimes extremism and
terrorism as well as on building trust
between police and communities they
serve each year ADL experts deliver
customized in-depth training on these
subjects to more than 15,000 federal
state and local law enforcement
personnel at to hundreds of agencies
nationwide ADL's dual role as a pretty
eminent civil rights organization and as
a strong and trusted partner of law
enforcement gives us the credibility to
offer a continuum of services that
influence the way law enforcement fights
hate and interacts with the communities
they serve
provides law enforcement with
extensive resources including analytical
reports as well as expertise and
actionable intelligence to prevent
disrupt and respond to those extremes to
cross a line from espousing hateful
ideologies to committing violent or
criminal acts thus protecting our
community although we monitor extremist
ideologies across the political spectrum
today we are going to focus on
right-wing extremism in particular white
supremacist conversations focused on
white supremacy have dominated the
public discourse as our country grapples
with the emergence of an ideology that
has historically lurked in the shadows
extremists felt emboldened particularly
partially by the divisive political
rhetoric that gained traction during the
2016 presidential campaign and by
xenophobic anti-muslim and misogynistic
tropes that emerged in our public sphere
much of what has been festering for the
last 18 months culminated as we spoke
about earlier with the unite the right
rally in Charlottesville
past August this event was significant
for a number of reasons first the hate
was both unmasked and Unleashed as
unabashedly smart in broad daylight
seconds anti-semitism was front and
center at this rally prior to
Charlottesville white supremacists
fixated on issues of immigration
refugees and Islam however these themes
were not the focus of Charlottesville
rather marchers shouted Heil Hitler
declared Jews as Satan's children and
chanted the refrain of Jews will not
replace us
third Charlottesville was the largest
public gathering of white supremacists
in at least a decade and the attendees
showcased a remarkable cohesion amongst
a broad cross-section of the white
supremacist movement while it was
organized by those aligned with the
alt-right
it was very much a big tent event
drawing together divergent racist
organizations and individuals that
historically do not collaborate whatever
disparities existed among ideologies and
uniforms the white supremacists saw this
as an opportunity to come together very
publicly to voice their beliefs on a
national stage the Albright movement
successfully activated participants from
over 30 states including our own great
state of California additionally this
rally drew many white supremacists who
never actively participated in the
movement in any such way prior over the
past ten years from 2007 to 2016
domestic extremists of all kinds have
killed at least 372 people in the United
States of those deaths approximately 74
percent we're at the hands of right-wing
extremists such as white supremacist
sovereign citizens and militia adherents
right-wing extremists have been
responsible for plotting at least a
hundred and fifty
of terror in the United States in the
past 25 years their anger is most
frequently directed against government
law enforcement and racial and religious
targets the most common religious
targets are Jews and Muslims while the
most common racial targets are African
Americans including most multiracial
targets the white supremacists who
target minority communities for acts of
terror and violence include adherents of
every major segment of their movement
including neo-nazis racist skinheads
traditional white supremacists such as
the Klan the religious sect Christian
identity white supremacist prison gang
z' and the newest subgroup the alts
right white supremacist ideology in the
u.s. today is dominated by the belief
that unless action is taken immediately
White's are doomed to extinction by a
rising tide of non-whites who are
controlled and manipulated by the Jews
this core belief exemplifies the slogans
such as the so called
14 words we must secure the existence of
our people and a future for white
children bringing it closer to home the
white supremacist landscape in
California has unique elements that
differ from the rest of the country
California has the largest racist
skinhead population in the u.s.
predominantly based in Southern
California adherence had have their own
unique subculture and are dedicated to
furthering Hitlerian ideology racist
skinheads range from a few members to
hundreds of members these groups
organized social events such as white
power music festivals like the one held
just two weeks ago in San Bernardino
honoring the life of an sword the
founder of the British white power band
screwdriver racist skinheads also engage
in political action like their so-called
quote white lives matter
protests of the alleged quote atrocities
that are being committed against white
people
unfortunately however their actions are
not limited to barbecues or protests but
often include the most violent hate
crimes one of the most shocking and well
publicized examples is that of Wade
Michael Page who in 2012 opened fire in
a Sikh temple in Oak Creek Wisconsin
killing six and wounding four before
shooting himself Paige was a member of
the hammer skins a racist skinhead group
lived and lived in Orange County
California for a period of time where he
played in the white power band definite
hate most white supremacist in
California do not belong to organized
hate groups but participate in the white
supremacist movement as unaffiliated
individuals this means the size of the
state's white supremacist population is
considerably larger than just the known
members of hate groups the counties with
the heaviest concentrations of white
supremacist activity include the Inland
Empire Riverside and San Bernardino
Antelope Valley Lancaster and Palmdale
Ventura County Orange County San Diego
as well as the region within the highway
99 corridor from Fresno to Sacramento
California has the most developed white
supremacist gang environment in the
country ideology amongst affiliates is
often tangential to their financial and
criminal enterprises
although Klan groups emerge from time to
time in California they tend to be small
and not very long-lasting aside from the
loyal white knights in Orange County
there are few even worth mentioning
in recent years white supremacist prison
gang are the only group to have
exhibited quantifiable growth becoming
an increasingly dangerous problem in
many areas of the US including
California
historically speaking two of the most
notorious white supremacist prison gang
the Aryan Brotherhood and the Nazi
lowriders can both trace their roots to
the California state prison system in
the 1960s and 70s respectively before
expanding to the federal bureau of
prison systems nationwide though termed
prison gangs because most formed and all
are active in prisons many of these
groups are as active on the streets as
behind bars this subset is preoccupied
with organized crime and as a
consequence ideological white supremacy
takes a backseat a distant backseat
sometimes to contraband drugs robberies
identity theft and other forms of
traditional crime the a/b NLR and racist
streaking public enemy number one all
have a significant presence in both the
CDC R as well as in jails throughout the
state all of these types of white
supremacist groups I've mentioned thus
far have a history of engaging in
violent criminal Informer ders two acts
of terrorism however the rise of the
alternative right has really transformed
the white supremacist landscape in
California and throughout the US by
repackaging age-old racist beliefs and
race-based ideology intellectual racists
such as the LOS angeles-based William
Johnson head of the white supremacist
American Freedom Party and dr. Kevin
Macdonald an anti-semitic former
professor of psychology at Cal State
Long Beach have influenced this growing
movement with their pseudo science and
race-based
thinking the Albright movement which
have emerged in the late 2000s also drew
inspiration from the online subculture
the message boards the image boards like
4chan H and reddit the online gaming
subculture the so-called men's movement
and others Richard Spencer remains the
movement
best-known American representative the
ideology of the alt-right is based on
standard white supremacist beliefs that
needs belief about the need to protect
the white race from this quote rising
tide of color combined by anti set with
anti-semitism Islamophobia xenophobia
nationalism considerable in the misogyny
and anti LGBTQ attitudes they cite
census charts white birth rates and
immigration policies in order to portray
themselves as victims under the guise of
preserving the ethnic genetic and
cultural origins of the quote Western
civilization's they espouse racism and
intolerance they issue multiculturalism
and diversity in favour of promoting
white interests white culture white
identity they do not make explicit
references to white supremacy like the
14 words a slogan used by neo-nazis and
other hardcore white supremacist but
they are more inclined to talk about
preserving the European American
identity all sugarcoating hate they
attempt to propagate their ideas among
more mainstream conservatives often
substituting lightning-rod terms such as
quote race with more palatable terms
such as culture demographically the
alt-right is young and largely male most
adherents of the alt-right are new to
white supremacy for most of its brief
history the alt-right has largely
existed online with few entities that
could be considered all right to quote
groups and few events related to the
outright taking place in the physical
world but that rapidly changed after the
2016 election where adherents became
emboldened with with many alt right
activists more eager to organize or
attend events in the real world one such
group identity Europa which has a
national presence embodies the alt-right
ideology and activism founded in early
2016 by Nathan
go an Iraq war veteran and student at
California State University Stanislaus
the white supremacist student group is
concerned concerned with preserving
quote white American culture and
promoting white identity at June 25th
2017 free speech rally in DC D'Amigo
said that America was founded by right
people for white people and was not
founded to be a multiracial or
multicultural society other alt-right
leaders including Tim Treadstone geonets
aka Baked Alaska of the San Fernando
Valley who has made a series of
anti-semitic tweets about Jewish control
of the media Gina has also dabbled in
white supremacist tropes posting on his
Twitter account a photo of a restaurant
receipt showing a tip for $14 and 88
cents a combination of two popular white
supremacist numeric symbols he wrote now
that Trump won I've decided to start
tipping my fellow human beings way more
extremists make up a tiny segment of our
population in the US but the internet
amplifies their voices it is important
to keep in mind that most extremists are
unaffiliated with organized groups and
the Internet has enabled isolated
extremists to become more active and
involved in virtual campaigns technology
allows hate groups and they're often
far-flung and anonymous supporters to
spread fear and terrorize communities
more quickly and with far greater
geographic reach than ever before with
the advent of live streaming extremist
groups like the alt right aligned red
elephants pace in Southern California
can also reach thousands of followers
from their smartphone and broadcast
their antics on a variety of social
media platforms in 2016 we saw white
supremacist from California robocalling
voters with messages supporting Trump
we saw them exploit security flaws in
network to compete printers to spew out
anti some
messages that were emitted to California
universities as far north as UC Santa
Cruz to such SoCal schools including USC
and Cal State Long Beach we also saw
them exploit Twitter to magnify their
voice and collectively harass reporters
in mass the impact of these online
tactics are evident here in California
as users of daily stormer website posted
personal details of Aaron's Road a
Jewish woman running for Congress in
California who became the target of an
extensive an ongoing campaign of
anti-semitic harassment daily death
threats and Holocaust related vitriol
last year language including fire up the
oven and all would laugh with glee as
they gang raped her and then bashed her
bagel eating brains in ADL stepped in to
help and provide support in conjunction
with law enforcement ADL has documented
that white supremacists assisted by the
greater reach provided by the Internet
are increasingly engaging in
unpresentable reach efforts to American
college campuses throughout the 2016-17
school year students faculty and staff
on a hundred and fifty four American
college campuses were confronted by 228
separate incidents of racist Flyers and
stickers with a disproportionate number
distributed in both California and Texas
California campuses throughout the state
have been targeted by this recruitment
effort in March a white supremacist
group Aryan underground even posted on a
High School in Riverside an anti-semitic
flier bearing the heading quote no kites
no problem white supremacist view young
people excuse me white supremacist you
view young people as prime targets in
part because they are still trying to
figure out who they are and what they
believe extremists also undoubtedly see
value in recruiting a new generation
that can
carry the movement for years to come
it's llama phobic and misogynist gadfly
Milo you nopales told CNN in February I
am speaking on college campuses because
education is really what matters it's a
crucible where these bad ideas are
formed bad ideas like progressive social
justice feminists black lives matter
following his disastrous free speech
week at Berkeley
you know Plus plans to hold additional
events on three college California
campuses in the upcoming months events
such as Milo's and other similar ones
remind us of the tension between First
Amendment rights and safety and security
in recent weeks law enforcement officers
throughout California have faced the
challenge of keeping the peace at a
number of far-right rallies and
demonstrations their task has been made
more difficult by the often heated
interactions between the white
supremacists and other bigots who have
shown up in Charlottesville Berkeley and
Laguna Beach and a relatively small
number of violent counter protesters
from the left especially and Tifa who
engage in violent confrontational
tactics this was the case in Anaheim in
February 2016 event corded bait
coordinated by the loyal white Knights
of the Ku Klux Klan and at a June 26
event in Sacramento which she spoke
about earlier organized by the white
supremacist group traditionalist Workers
Party attracting Golden State skinheads
and California skinheads more recently
confrontations between far-right
demonstrators and counter protesters in
the Bay Area and Laguna Beach have
resulted in clashes injuries and arrests
striking the right balance in terms of
response from the perspective of law
enforcement community and political fish
officials continues to be a problem
while we cannot legislate tabulate
regulate or arrest our way to a hate
free society there are steps that you
and your colleagues in the California
Legislature can take to prevent confront
and respond to hate in our society for
seize every opportunity to stand up and
speak out against hate this includes
condemning hateful ideas and actions
through resolutions and statements as
well as bringing communities together in
the aftermath of a hate incident ADL
urges legislators to speak out
vociferous ly immediately and directly
when hateful rhetoric comes to their
district
this requires being equally concerned
about instances of bias direct against
any group second advocate and support
legislative efforts to improve reporting
and response to hate crimes
bias-motivated violence and extremism we
know for instance that hate crimes are
grossly under reported nationally and
California is no exception
did you know that almost 300 cities in
California
affirmative ly reported zero hate crimes
for the most recent FBI stats of 2015
hate crime report this includes seven
cities with a population over a hundred
thousand one city with a population over
200 thousand and one with a population
of 350,000 this past session a bill
creating a state reporting hotline for
hate crimes was introduced but did not
pass perhaps it is worthwhile to
consider something similar in the future
ADL also recommends supporting efforts
to strengthen laws that can prevent hate
incidents and hate crimes including the
state's anti-bullying laws ensure that
all of your school districts have
up-to-date comprehensive policies that
have been disseminated to teachers staff
and parents and are implemented
consistently third education is crucial
ADL's nationally recognized anti-bias
program posit that people are not born
hating rather hate is learned and can be
unlearned supporting anti-bias education
in schools and places of employment is
the key element to building communities
founded on understanding and respectful
dialogue in your packets today our
additional resources to further educate
you on this top
and solutions to address what we've
discussed today and I appreciate that
and I wanted to cut you off so we get we
do have a couple quick questions the
rest of the materials here I think will
be very helpful let me just simply start
the questions I know senator Stern had
one as well so we're seeing this
increase in hate speech hate crimes hate
groups what actions would you recommend
that the state of California
specifically take in order to
effectively prevent the growth of these
groups you mentioned education you
mentioned a hotline to report hate
crimes you mentioned anti-bullying laws
are there any other things specifically
that you would mention that this group
and and the members of the legislature
can do to try to stop this particularly
egregious situation unfortunately
there's no magic bullet there's no magic
bullet that can be implemented a
holistic approach is necessary education
is significant changing hearts and minds
I'm speaking out really using your bully
pulpit to challenge to identify and to
name the hate and to really be allowed
and strong and clear voice against it
educating and working with law
enforcement making sure that they have
the resources and the tools to respond
to identify criminal behavior and
activity by these extremist groups that
they have all the resources is effective
as well working on hate crime laws and
making sure that they are implemented
throughout the state again the fact that
there is actively zero reporting in so
many states as cities throughout our
city throughout our state is is
significant and so it's it's really
approaching this with a holistic and
kind of big-picture approach thank you
very much senator Stern I know you had a
question thank you madam chair thank you
miss Mendelsohn for your presentation I
I wanted to drill down on this this
resource question you guys have been a
huge resource and we really appreciate
what you've been doing on the
nonprofit front unfortunately the
federal government has been derelict I
think in their duties for providing the
adequate training that we really need
for law enforcement personnel I know
that after Oklahoma City there was a
state and local anti-terrorism training
process put together and there were
fusion centers established all over the
country and after Charlottesville it
came to light that all that funding has
been cut so there currently is no source
of federal funds I just wondered if you
could comment on the importance of
having you know when it when it when
things rise well beyond hate speech and
they actually become about planning for
acts of violence hopefully not but
potentially on a massive scale what more
can we be doing on that front and do you
see those those sort of fusion centers
or other sort of anti domestic terrorism
networks is able to break up say some of
those prison gang networks that may
actually culminate into larger acts of
violence afterwards you're absolutely
right
law enforcement need those resources
they need that training if they're
unaware of the activities and the
indicators the identifiers is occurring
on the ground then they can't address
the issues that are lurking and so it's
important to create those programs
create those trainings the the resources
the fusion centers have been a great way
to address this we work closely with I
here in California with Jarek o'ciock
Nick Rick and all the various fusion
centers that are trying to piece
together the information and in
intelligence we're dealing with a
massive amount of information especially
with the internet right and trying to
uncover and to spotlight extremist
groups and their activities and to to
narrow in on the criminal nature of
these groups is very important whatever
funding whatever resources law
enforcement can have at their disposal
certainly a very significant way of
responding to this problem and I know
that law enforcement will be coming up
to just talk about just this issue and
I'm sure we'll be making the same pitch
for money
as everyone else always does senator
more like one quick one question and
then we will have to thank you so much
for your testimony senator Morley thank
you madam chair thank you miss
Mendelsohn or maybe instead of a
question this may be a reaction or just
an observation because you're given us
three things to do and you know one is
to speak out and the other is to educate
and so I just wanted to make an
observation that and thank you for
giving me your speech in typing it all
out I appreciate it but on page seven
without any prior mention or detail we
we are introduced to someone named Milo
Jana polis and and and his introduction
is done I think it may be in a hateful
way or maybe maybe maybe it should say
instead of Islam Islamophobic and
misogynist gadfly Milo maybe it should
be Milo who some consider you know so
that it isn't like you're attacking him
or you know hey I just think maybe the
next time you could change that a little
bit because it seems II D hominem so I
would say maybe lead by example cuz we
go I know we all can't be Gandhi and
just not deal with these issues but you
do give balance and that is you mention
at the end of your remarks that that
there are a small number of violent
counter-protesters from the left
especially an Tifa who engaged in
confrontational tactics but I see a lot
of pages on one side well done but I'd
see a little less attention on the
others that have been extremely
disruptive to what should be community
events in Orange County where I'm from
so I just give those those observations
and thank you for coming thank you mark
so first of all it hyperlinks to my leg
innopolis five things to know about him
and we have a background or on our
website for further information and
resources just to point out second of
all in terms of domestic terrorism in
terms of the violence perpetrated by
extremist groups across the continuum to
dates white supremacist and
anti-government extremists mainly
right-wing extremists carry out the
majority of the violence and the murder
perpetrated here domestically to date
and Tifa have not committed murder where
there's no record of an int if a related
murder and so certainly the tactics any
violent tactics by either side is should
be condemned and in in in in many ways
the tactics of antifa really subvert and
undermined the the message to challenge
hate and to respond effectively thank
you very much and we appreciate your
testimony and the good work that you're
doing it's stunning the number of hate
groups that we see out there and
defining hate of course is sometimes
difficult but when someone tries to
marginalize demean ridiculed undervalue
others I think that's certainly a pretty
decent definition of hate so appreciate
the work that you're doing in the ADL as
well so with that we thank you and we'll
call up our third panel we have what
we're talking about is you know public
expressions of hate like like what we
saw in Charlottesville do impact all of
us and they they undermine our common
humanity so we recognized that that that
the speech that does that that
undermines our humanity that vilifies
others really does impact our our common
humanity our communities and so forth
and while we acknowledge that free
expression does include the right to
engage in that speech it is important I
think to acknowledge and take seriously
the particularly heavy weight and the
disproportionate burden that falls on
the targets of that hate speech so that
is the purpose of our next panel it
consists of Syed is Assad swayam Salem
my apologies
for my mispronunciation but we do know
that you are a civil rights attorney
with the Council on american-islamic
relations if you'd like to take a seat
up here sir then we have Jessica a true
bewitch who is a community building
director of the Jewish Community
Relations Council and show Michael who
is the manager of a legislative manager
excuse me of equality California Joseph
B Ella director of policy for the
Coalition for humane immigrant rights
and Eric Harris who is the chief
lobbyist for the n-double-a-cp
California chapter we have up to 45
minutes for this panel so that we get to
hear ampli from each one of you I would
please ask you encourage you prod you
and insist that you not exceed seven
minutes each with your comments and that
will allow for some additional questions
from the panel so with that let's start
with mr. Suellen do I have that
pronounced properly my apology sir
alrighty and seven minutes or if you
would good morning hello and peace be
upon you my name is Saad sway law and
civil rights attorney here with Cara
California our community has experienced
and continues to experience very
challenging times thank you for inviting
me to share this experience with you
today I hope that we can work together
to make California a better place for
everyone including the 800,000 Muslims
living in our great state to start off
the American Muslim community has
experienced a huge increase in hate
incidents and hate attacks all over the
country cares 2017 annual report on
civil rights shows that asama phobic
bias continues its trend toward
increasing violence against our
community in 2016
care recorded at 57% increase an
anti-muslim bias incidents over 2015
this was accompanied by a 44% increase
in anti increase in anti-muslim hate
crimes in the same period from 2014 to
2016 anti-muslim bias incidents jumped
sixty-five percent in that two year
period
Kara finds that hate crimes targeting
Muslims surged 584 percent the FBI's own
2015 report found that there was an
increase of 67 percent in hate attacks
against the Muslim community from 2014
to 2015 that was reported to them the
unfortunate white trend has at home here
in California repeatedly as well here in
Sacramento we've had numerous mosques
vandalized and an attack to this past
year alone we also saw neo-nazi rally
that turned violent last year as
protesters were stabbed throughout the
state we've seen an unfortunate attacks
on the Muslim community from SoCal to
North Cal Central California and
everywhere in between these incidents
have a real impact to our community and
something as basic as going to the
mosque for prayer but can become
intimidating and frightening a
nerve-wracking experience most
unfortunate however is the clear
evidence that this hate and fear has
trickled down into our schools and
directly impacted our children our
bullying studies consistently show that
Muslim students in public school are
bullied at a rate that's twice as high
as the national statistic that for
regarding students reporting bullying at
school our most recently published
school bullying report found that over
55 percent of American Muslims students
attending public schools in California
have reported some sort of bullying
based on their religious identity
perhaps most alarming the bullying was
bullying is often physical almost 30
percent 30 percent of a job wearing the
sonic headscarf students reported
offensive touching or pulling of their
head job at school studies have
repeatedly shown that bullying can have
serious and long-lasting impacts on the
ends on the psychological health and
mental mental well-being of our youth
we've seen this happening in real time
over the past year the crisis text line
a major crisis organized crisis
counseling organization that caters to
youth and teens reported a 600 percent
increase in intakes involving Muslim
youth in October of 2016
900 percent increase immediately
following the November election the
struggle is experienced by Muslim youth
in our California schools have become a
major concern for our community and a
focal point of our work we're finding
that not only does not only does student
on student bullying impact our youth but
so does the inability of faculty and
staff members to properly respond to
these incidents in some cases we've
union seen teachers themselves
perpetuate sama phobic rhetoric within
their curriculum or worse target
students because of their faith and our
last bullying report one in five Muslim
students reported being discriminated
against by a staff member at their own
school last year we were able to work
together to pass a b28 for five the
school safety the school safety is a
safe place to learn act in hopes of
providing schools the guidelines they
need to make sure that our kids are safe
and protected unfortunately most of a
b28 four or five with ceremonial the one
thing that this legislature can do is to
provide protection and support for the
Muslim community by protecting its
children ensuring that every student has
a safe place to thrive and learn should
be a major focus for all California's
Californians this this year we did push
131 a sponsored by Assemblymember
David Chiu however it did not pass that
that bill attempted to add a little bit
of teeth basically to an eighty to
eighty four five it was going to give
employees training and resources that
they need to respond to this very
serious issue of Muslim and also really
seek students and others who people
perceive to be Muslim who are being
bullied every day at school it also
attempted to add a reporting requirement
as well so you know I'm hopeful that in
the future you know with these very real
stats these incidents are happening that
we can all work together to hopefully
provide resources that are needed to
respond to this situation thank you
thank you very much miss trooper which
seven minutes if you would the focusing
on the the impacts that this level of
hate crime is having on the Jewish
community thank you good morning my name
is Jessica
to voyage and I am the director of
public policy and community building at
the Jewish Community Relations Council
of San Francisco Bay Area I am also here
today representing the Jewish public
affairs committee of California the
Jewish Community Relations Council
believes in a strong civil and
democratic society and that the Jewish
community has a special interest in
safeguarding our democracy when there
are strains in the Democratic fabric of
our society discrimination occurs
against our own community and other
racial religious and ethnic minority
communities our organization advocates
for a just society and for security for
all minority groups thank you to the
Senate Committee on the of the judiciary
for holding this hearing today it is
reassuring to know that you the elected
leaders of our state are paying
attention to the rise of hate occurring
in California I appreciate being asked
to talk about the impact of
anti-semitism on our community as I
begin to speak about the Jewish
community experience I must acknowledge
that we are not a heterogeneous group we
are people of many different racial
ethnic and gender identities so while I
speak for a large group of the Jewish
community I cannot speak to all the ways
anti-semitism may be experienced
especially when intersects with other
forms of discrimination or bias in 2016
California had the highest rate of
anti-semitic incidents of vandalism
assault and harassment of all 50 states
and make no mistake our community is
feeling under attack with social media
with social media our elementary middle
and high school students are receiving
an increasing number of hateful messages
and frankly it is scared to the child
and to the parents some real-life
examples you are a big nosed people
hate Jews because of that little country
of yours meaning Israel and Hitler's
biggest mistake was not killing your
family our young people come face to
face with Nazi salutes graffiti hateful
notes and
harassment at school and when the
harassment is about Israel or related to
the past it's rarely past me in conflict
it is dismissed as merely political
there is no little or no understanding
of the connection between Jews and the
Jewish state of Israel we have heard
from parents who feel outraged and
heartbroken about by the continued
anti-semitic actions that remain
unaddressed in so many schools Jewish
students on college campuses are
increasingly isolated and ostracized by
other students and staff who adhere to
anti normalization which calls for an
end to all interactions with anyone who
does not have a particular viewpoint on
Israel Zionism or there's Rayleigh
Palestinian conflict all too familiar a
scenario for many of our Jewish students
whatever their personal beliefs about
Israel is being intentionally left out
of events and told that they must choose
between their Jewish identity and
participating in Jewish organizations
and their own participation in social
justice activities stuff some students
feel compelled to hide their identities
as Jews October 2017 having to hide your
identity as on a progressive public
campus in Oakland last week a synagogue
was vandalized as hundreds of people
prepared to observe Rosh Hashanah one of
our holiest days a few weeks before that
white supremacist groups attempted to
hold rallies in San Francisco and in
Berkeley even as we experienced great
fear from these acts
we were resolute We strongly believe in
freedom of speech and at the same time
we stand against hate and bigotry we
found expression for these sometimes
dueling values in the many ways we
organize our response to white
supremists in our town over a thousand
people joined an interfaith prayer
service at a local synagogue and many
Jews peacefully marched
led by a 95 year old Holocaust survivor
in the rally against hate the moral
leadership of the Senate demonstrated in
holding this hearing and in passing a
resolution earlier this session
condemning anti-semitism is an example
to the people of California and for
governments of other states I also want
to thank our friends and allies at
equality California for their support of
this resolution having friends and
allies matter our community recognizes
that anti-semitism does not happen in a
vacuum
Jonathan Sacks former chief rabbi of
Britain said anti-semitism is the
world's most reliable earning early
warning sign of major threats to freedom
humanity and the dignity of difference
many other peoples are victims of
discrimination perpetrated by hateful
individuals and by our own broken
systems and institutions we as a Jewish
community stand with our brothers and
sisters in those impacted communities at
this time we also are prepared to be of
service to you our elected officials as
you grapple with how to address the hate
and bigotry occurring in our state thank
you very much and perhaps during the Q&A
period we can ask what some of those
ideas are that you think would be
helpful Jo Michael who appears regularly
in our legislative sessions and
certainly in our committee always a
pleasure to have you here and if you
could share with us the impacts that
hate speech and this hate and violence
have had on the LGBTQ community thank
you madam chair and good morning i madam
chair and committee members
I am Jo Michael legislative manager at
equality California an organization that
brings the voices of lesbian gay
bisexual transgender and queer people
and allies to institutions of power in
California and across the United States
driving striving to create a world that
is healthy just and fully equal for all
LGBTQ people unfortunately we all face
rising hates rising rates of hate crimes
and bias-motivated violence here in
California
and across the u.s. people of color
immigrants Muslims the Jewish community
women people with disabilities and
members of the LGBTQ community are
targeted frequently to make matters
worse many incidents are not reported
because members of these communities
often feel unsafe interacting with law
enforcement officials and fear being
ignored or even targeted by them as well
according to the most recent hate the
hate crime victimization report by the
Bureau of Justice Statistics over half
of hate crimes nationally go unreported
to law enforcement to speak specifically
to hate crimes and the LGBTQ community
for a moment hate crimes where the
sexual orientation bias have
consistently been the second most common
type of hate crime in California for
more than 10 years and have accounted
for nearly a quarter of all hate crimes
reported in California over each of the
past three years hate crimes with a bias
against gay men in particular increased
over 40 percent between 2015 and 2016
in 2015 hate crimes against transgender
and gender non-conforming people
accounted for over 90% of the hate
crimes based on gender in California
hate crimes and hate violence have
unique repercussions extending beyond
the individual's targeted to others in
the communities of which those
individuals are a part creating a sense
of isolation and vulnerability to harm
among people with shared core
characteristics California's hate crime
laws provide protection based on a
person's actual or perceived race or
ethnicity nationality religion
disability gender identity and
expression and sexual orientation in
addition to providing legal recourse for
people targeted by hate crimes
enumerated
of these groups helps to raise awareness
of the impact of hate crimes on each of
these communities and on individuals who
are part of more than more than one
marginalized community for example LGBTQ
people who are also of color face higher
risks of experiencing hate violence the
same is true of LGBTQ people who are
also immigrants or who also have
disabilities in considering how to
address the increases in hate violence
we would be well-served to look closely
at the experiences of people who are
part of multiple marginalized
communities and to listen to their
stories and ID
it's important to note that although
California's existing law is strong and
inclusive we at equality California know
that more needs to be done to address
the increase and hate-motivated
incidents that marginalized communities
are facing we sponsored two pieces of
legislation in this past year and
supported two others that would have
improved California's law on hate crime
specifically including sparking review
of local hate crimes policies and
providing additional avenues for redress
for targeted individuals and communities
although those pieces of legislation did
not move forward this year a statewide
audit of hate crimes laws and
implementation was approved by the joint
legislative audit committee committee an
audit that we requested along with many
of the organizations represented here
today and with the main authorship of
Assemblymember kansen Chu we await the
results of that audit already knowing
anecdotally that LGBTQ people and
members of other marginalized
communities in California are still
being targeted based on who they are and
that they do not feel safe reporting
when they have experienced a hate
incident we hope the audit will provide
more specific insight into where the
gaps in implementing the current law are
so that future policy making efforts can
focus on filling those gaps or creating
new ways to get around them in addition
to policy changes that would better
address hate violence we know it is
crucial for marginalized communities to
continue to come together to support
each other and help keep each other safe
for the LGBTQ community in particular
weird equality California will continue
to partner with service providers and
with organizations that serve and
advocate for all marginalized
communities of which LGBTQ people are a
part to continue to work toward a future
that is safer for all of us we thank you
for holding this hearing today and for
listening to all of us thank you
thank you so much mr. Harris with the
n-double-a-cp welcome and if you would 7
minutes and if you have any suggestions
on what we can do as a legislature to
assist that would be helpful to hear as
well right thank you madam chair and
thank you members my name is Eric Harris
I'm the California I'm the chief
lobbyist for the California State
Conference of the n-double a-c-p
I wanted to give you first
information nationally about hate crimes
in recent years because the federal
information most recent numbers are from
2015 Brian Levin a professor at the
California State University of San
Bernardino for the Center for study of
hate and extremism has the very recent
report where he looks at some of the
largest cities in the United States and
how hate crimes have risen over the last
couple of years hate crimes in Chicago
rose over 20 percent hate crimes in New
York City have risen over 24 percent
hate crimes in Los Angeles have risen
over 15 percent in 2016 there were very
significant increases around the
election of President Donald Trump
campaign rhetoric has emboldened and
mainstreamed white nationalism as
Professor 11 points out this only paints
a partial picture many hate crimes are
not reported properly as Joe Michael
just stated we worked really hard the
n-double-a-cp other groups Disability
Rights California arc equality
California and several others including
the Jewish community and the Muslim
community worked really hard on a
legislative audit with the jail AG
committee and Assemblymember Chiu on on
an audit for the state of California and
increasing the improvement on reporting
hate crimes properly and educating the
community as well as different agencies
including the police department on hate
crimes as far as the african-american
community 59% of hate crimes are with
racial or ethnic bias 52% of those are
with african-american bias
african-americans are the number one
victimized group in the United States
and in the state of California as
victims of hate crimes and have been for
a number of years
hate crimes include violent physical
crimes to the person and damage damage
of their property and businesses it is
important to remember the different
incidents that have happened over the
last couple of years throughout the
country including Charleston South
Carolina where individuals gathering at
a church were brutally murdered
Charlottesville Virginia as we all have
spoken about earlier and the reason we
are here today celebrities like NBA
player LeBron James
NFL players NFL players who have
protested during the national anthem for
racial injustice I've also been faced
with threats of violence Bakari
henderson who is a who was a recent
graduate of the university of arizona
and a citizen of austin texas was
brutally murdered overseas in Greece by
Serbians
I actually spoke with his mother earlier
today and she was very proud that the
state of California is taking a lead on
this very important issue and just last
week in the United States Air Force
Academy where individuals African
American cadets were faced with racist
racist language with the message go home
as written on message boards for
five African American cadets
the political climate and inspires many
knots of fear what is going on and not
to fear the consequences of hate crimes
it's important also to remember the
intersectionality of the different
groups I know that I'm here representing
the n-double-a-cp of California but I am
also a member of the disability
community I see different biases and
different hate directed towards both the
disability community that I am a part of
and the african-american community that
I'm a part of and it's important to know
and understand that people were ever
present in different groups often times
african-americans in the Muslim
community african-americans in the
disability community and
african-americans and other groups are
the highest are still the highest
victims of these hate crimes dr. Robert
Carter of Columbia University in New
York talks about this as well as
race-based traumatic stress injury it's
a type it's a name that he put on this
issue and he believes that a name should
be put on different types of race trauma
trauma has an impact on the
african-american community in many ways
including raising but higher blood
pressure stress and other forms of
mental health harm one may express
trauma through anxiety anger rage
depression low self-esteem shame and
guilt often times people in the
african-american community are afraid to
seek help when it comes to any type of
mental mental harm a diagnosis of
clinical depression or anxiety alone
could be made in certain circumstances
yet this would not include some of the
racial aspects and it is important that
this is recognized in order for a person
to recognize racism he or she must have
developed a mature racial identity ego
status to be able to preach to
appreciate the racial understanding of
their own demographic racial group in
their own race and culture are valued
symptoms of racial trauma increased
sensitivity to threat increased
psychological and physiological symptoms
increased alcohol and drug abuse
increased aggression narrowing sense of
time there are ways that the
african-american community is responding
and I listed some of the negative ones
earlier so I'm going to say some of the
positive things that people can do
affirmation or acknowledgement it's
important that professionals family
friends help the person develop
understanding acceptance of racial
issues this helps open the door to
dialogue about race create a safe space
for race take a proactive role to
identify race as a significant variable
and talk openly about experiences
related to race racial storytelling give
individuals an outlet to share personal
experiences validation counter and
counter devaluate devaluation process of
naming race based traumatic stress
syndrome helps give these experiences
legitimacy externalized devaluation and
counteract evaluation also find ways to
reach annal rage engage in activism or
self-care strategies such as spending
time with family members exercising and
other forms to reach an older age as far
as ideas that the California State
Legislature can continue to do I want to
along with Joe Michael thank
Assemblymember kansen Chu for his
efforts and his staff with great
leadership along with the jail AG
committee who worked with the
Californian double acp and other civil
rights groups on an audit to understand
how we are doing reporting in California
we know that the numbers are much lower
than they should be and much lower than
they really are so we appreciate that
the Californian double ACP believes that
it is important to educate the community
and enforcement agencies so that
everyone is aware of hate crimes and
what to look for to indicate that one
has been committed the african-american
community and then double acp are trying
to make sure that the community
understands potential dangerous
situations and finally then double acp
encourages african-americans to get help
if necessary for any trauma that they
might be going through as a result of
any hate crime or racism
thank you thank you very much for your
testimony I have my district director as
a fellow who once every quarter does
something called coffee with a black guy
and it's amazing the number of people
show up and they just talk in my
community where we have very limited
number of african-americans the
population think in my districts one and
a half percent we found that just
talking just sharing our humanity seems
to be an enormous ly successful way to
bridge some of those gaps so thank you
for your testimony and our final speaker
in this panel and then we'll open it up
to questions is Joseph ei pronounce it
for me will you Joseph Adela Vieira who
is the director of policy with the
Coalition for humane immigrant rights
always a pleasure to see you thank you
good morning members of this committee
my name is Joseph vigil again policy
director with Sheila Sheila is a
crossroads organization statewide
presence and with national impact we
organize immigrant families college
students whom are undocumented as well
as immigrant workers the protection of
the First Amendment is critical to chill
our membership as we utilize to bring
awareness of the current challenges of
our of our members however we are
concerned with the current language to
describe immigrants in such divisive
weight in a halfway and analysis that
also incites violence to where our
immigrant communities in a couple of our
events that we had in in in areas in
which these groups white supremacist
groups are are are more common
membership our membership have felt
threatened by them as we attend and
exercise our First Amendment we
encountered them and this white
supremacist groups they tend to
intimidate our members verbally insult
them and also in some cases I stopped
them to their cars as we walk away from
the the public event during the 2016
presidential elections the attacks
towards immigrants communities became a
mainstream in accepted
unfortunately words became actions this
this claim is backed by three different
reports one by the report
mentioned by my colleague Eric the other
ones by the report by the Attorney
General who released a report in in July
in regards to to hate crimes and also by
the Los Angeles County Commission of
human relations when the AG released its
report his report it indicated that
between 2015 and 2016 hate crimes events
increased by 11 percent it also
indicated that hate crimes event
involving racial bias bias increased 21%
the Los Angeles Kanak County Commission
also found that in Los Angeles County
area anti-latino hate crime jump to 69%
the first amendment is a 10 in our
Constitution but also but it also we
must also protect all our community in
regards to to him words matter and
discriminatory language does not make a
stronger bite actually devices and put
the safety of our community at risk this
is why not only condemning a crime is
critical but then also acting to protect
all communities and this hearing is
critical is the critical first step to
ensure that we distinguish between First
Amendment right and also the protection
of all individuals we recommend first
that this legislature and law
enforcement build and rebuild trust
between immigrant communities and local
law enforcement you cannot have
immigrant communities report crimes when
they are afraid of being deported and so
that's the first initial step second we
also liked the AG office to increase its
funding or methodology to ensure that
all the report crimes are actually
reported but also coordinating with
local governments to assess what is the
local response and avoid
one-size-fits-all but we also recommend
advancing community policy models
immigrants like I said will not feel
comfortable in reporting crimes if they
cannot trust local law enforcement but
also we need to be mindful that
communities of collaring
have faced different challenges when
encountering local law enforcement we
have to take that into consideration if
we want them to report crimes also it's
important to note that children born
outside America or
into immigrant families are more likely
to become victims of bullying as
compared with kids born in the u.s. so
we also like to see that like his
lecture either work with the state
superintendent or or direct the
superintendent to upgrade his bullying
policies lastly in the state current
statute on hate crimes they the current
statute that that covers what is a hate
crime is is define someone that is
criminalized by disability gender
nationality race ethnicity religion and
sexual orientation we proposed to what
the day cream hate crime statute
citizenship or immigration status to
also ensure that we cover a new
phenomenon when it comes to attacking
Eric immigrant communities I like to
thank the chairwoman for putting this
panel together and and for all the work
that she's been doing in regards to this
thank you so much thank you very much
and appreciate the testimony of all of
you and recognized to this is a
collaborative effort because hate
frequently will express itself at
particulars but hate is hate and you
know we could substitute one group for
another as certain points in time when
people are really espousing hatred for
other people it it strikes me as just
dawned on me you know the the day after
the inauguration of this president there
were marches around the world three
million people marched there wasn't a
single incident not a single incident of
violence not a single arrest made I
happened to be in Los Angeles where they
expected a hundred thousand people to
show up and there were 750 thousand and
I spent at least a good 40 minutes stuck
literally stuck in some poor guy's
armpit because we couldn't move
literally could not move
there wasn't an act of hostility it was
an extraordinary moment when you think
about it throughout the entire world and
I guess my question is why and yet when
we are seeing public expressions of
political or other points of view are we
so much violence and so much hatred and
so much bigotry to each group that's
sitting here at this table and I know to
our disability community as well and
other minority groups that are being
singled out or mutually I guess not just
singled out but groups in general for
this this hatred that we didn't talk
necessarily about misogyny that
certainly is a big problem as we're
seeing an increase in violent crime
against women and so forth so I would
like to ask the the suggestions you
might have we talked about some of them
dealing with the victims of this hatred
that it does hurt it does hurt and we
have mental health problems that are
existing in this kind of behavior seems
I suspect to exacerbate the problem talk
a little bit if you would about if you
were I like to say this if you were
master of the universe what would you do
to remove hatred from people's hearts
how would you go about doing it is it
through education is it through
interactions what what would you what
would you do if we could do anything to
try to really take hate out of people's
hearts and replace it with kindness and
compassion and empathy an easy question
I know but just it it strikes me that
that really may be where we need to be
going we can disagree we can disagree I
don't know if they're ever going to
figure out the israeli-palestinian
problem I don't know I mean I remember
the times when we had Northern Ireland
and there was no hope that that country
would reunite but it has and then the
Vietnam War and now that's right I mean
that there there there are challenges
but what do we do to get people to treat
each other with respect and dignity even
if they don't agree we don't have to
worry we shouldn't agree if we did we
wouldn't be human beings so anyone want
to throw kind of take that question and
run with it for a minute or two yes mr.
Harris yes so I have a couple of
different ideas one thing that we can do
is
educate people as early as possible and
one of the ways that we can do that one
of the ways I'll speak for myself one of
the ways that I've been able to
understand and get along with people who
are different from me is by
participating in sporting events on
sports teams I've participated on sports
teams my entire life
and being in different groups have
participated with disability groups I've
participated with groups of people of
color I've participated in a lot of
different groups with people who are
different from me and people who are
similar to me and when we're in those
groups and in those organizations we
have to work together in order to
accomplish some of the some of the goals
that we're looking to accomplish and I
think that being raised that way being
raised by my parents that way being
raised by other members of the community
that way it's really encouraged me to
develop an empathy for people who who
might be different from me but it allows
me to do my best to understand that
although they might be different from me
although although I might not be able to
experience some of the same things that
they've experienced I can put that aside
for at that time and really care for
them as individuals or them as groups so
I think that educating especially
children as early as possible on working
together and being okay and being
comfortable with speaking with and
working with people who are different
from them and people who might not
necessarily come from the same
background in same circumstances ISM is
probably one of the best places to start
thank you
anyone else there's Michael if I may add
to that yeah one of the things that I
didn't talk about is exactly what what
mr. Harris was just describing and in
terms of early Meneses airily
intervention but certainly early
education and talking with young people
about how to prevent intergroup conflict
and the the bill that the representative
from care actually mentioned we were a
co-sponsor
of that bill by Assemblymember David Shu
that also did not proceed through the
whole process this year unfortunately
and the the idea of that was to create a
system to address intergroup conflict in
schools and make it so that students
have a better idea of what it means to
be a part of different communities and
how to be welcoming and and inclusive
rather than have an an immediate
reaction of excluding other students and
how to kind of navigate that whole
process from as early an age as possible
so it would definitely agree with that
recommendation and you know there are
many different ways to actually put
something like that into place from a
policy level clearly there are some
challenges to doing that through
legislation so we've been thinking about
other other ways to approach that issue
creatively and perhaps to work with at
the State Superintendent and and other
local school districts to try to create
some of those programs and see if they
really would work on the ground so
that's something that we've been
considering as well but definitely would
agree with getting that to people as
early as possible in school being a good
opportunity to do that thank you did you
have a question mr. Moore look thank you
madam chair the Human Human Relations
Commission's were raised a few times and
we have a rather robust one in Orange
County and we try to monitor hate crimes
and get statistics every year in 2015
assembly member Shirley Weber wrote a B
953 the racial and identity profiling
Act of 2015 which would require police
officers to identify the ethnicity of
the person that they pulled over so that
they could do a little more analysis of
the data so the anti-defamation league
has said you know point two we'd like
more reporting more data this bill was
opposed by most police departments and
Public Safety officials because it means
more work it means adding another box to
the form and I think Miss Webber had to
actually extend the implementation date
Justice this year but I voted for that
bill I might have been the only
Republican that did because so many
public safety officials opposed it
I think gather gathering data is really
critical so I'm I'm curious are you
getting satisfactory data and is there
something else that we could add to
these reports that are required to be
filled in by our Public Safety officials
that might be helpful in getting that
data to you I can speak at least
previously to that as well my
understanding is that that data isn't
yet being collected because at that
process hasn't fully completed to
actually get those forms on the ground
to law enforcement under that piece of
legislation I but there was a great deal
of work to create what those forms would
include and there actually is an
identity aspect specific to the LGBTQ
community as well that we worked on at
equality California so we're hopeful
that once that data does get collected
it will be helpful because of that whole
process to try to set it up as well as
possible in the beginning and law
enforcement was very collaborative I
would say during that process once the
bill had already been passed inside so
that was I think hopefully a good
experience for everyone who was a part
of creating those forms and so it was
two years ago
I don't recall all the details I try to
look it up online Eric I apologize
that's what I was doing when you were
talking because you gave me some ideas
but does it include religious like Sikhs
Muslim Jewish Christian these Christians
are feeling a lot of hate lately too so
no yeah would that be helpful I would
say yes it would be healthy well
certainly we will work to make sure that
this is implemented as soon as possible
because there seems to be a common theme
that we that hate crimes are not being
reported that we're not getting the data
that we need were just all dealing
anecdotally there are many many many
many anecdotes unfortunately but it
would be helpful to get this information
so I appreciate you raising their
question thank you all very much very
briefly because we're right at the time
limit thanks thank you madam chair a
quick question in a comment thank you
all this collection of individuals
representing these organizations is very
special and I want to acknowledge
how important this this entire panel
standing here together unified on these
subjects is you know when we had a
Muslim gentleman stabbed in a mosque
this past year in Simi Valley right in
the heart of my community you know the
Jewish community the LGBT community
stepped up but you know we see on
campuses with a comment I wanted to make
is we see on college campuses and high
school campuses they're so so easy to
divide ourselves and you see micro
fractures within even the communities
that are represented here opposing one
another on various issues and I wanted
it is a scar their efforts that is sort
of both interfaith and Inter you know
ethnicity inter-gender any collaborative
efforts going on between your
organizations to sort of put out a
broader message so that you know there's
a task force at least out there that
that if a Muslim student is targeted on
a campus that there is a diverse
cross-section of people there to step up
and back them up and and vice versa a
Jewish student LGBT student black
student immigrant students so their
efforts going on sort of X outside of
the government arena because some of
this stuff we can't control and some of
the efforts from Sacramento actually may
be detrimental if we were to come down
and say crack down on certain speech on
campus or impose new guidelines that it
might actually have the opposite effect
but I wonder as leaders and advocates of
folks who who you know students will
look to your leadership are there
efforts going on sort of for
collaboration there I just said you know
with care for us here locally especially
in Sacramento there's definitely you
know collaboration when when the Davis
mosque was attached for example there
was just outpouring of support not just
from Muslim community but from the
Jewish community the Christian community
there was an interfaith event so for us
locally and you know we've definitely
worked with equality California and
we've you know we were here at the table
I think a lot of our organizations have
worked together you know whether it's
pushing forth legislation or just you
know holding a rally advocacy work
whatever it may be you know if it's
oftentimes for example we come up
I know your rights events the immigrant
community undocumented community or the
Muslim community oftentimes there's a
lot of intersectional issues here that
plays so there's definitely a lot of
collaboration going on locally
definitely come on let me just add so if
you all were able to come up with some
kind of framework state live a state why
do you felt confident I I know at least
on behalf of working with the
legislative Jewish caucus and try to
establish a sort of a mirror here
between the other ethnic caucuses and
the LGBT and the Women's Caucus we
might be able to find some interesting
partnerships just as advocates but the
quick question I had on a on a purely
policy level was on the fusion centers I
didn't hear much commentary on that are
you guys familiar with that does any of
that domestic terrorism the fallout and
funding there is that of concern to you
were just not on your radar that was I
had the same question for ADL but at
least for as we you know in LAPD we have
trying to make sure that there is
understanding you know public safety you
know concerns that they that they have
raised to us I think for us we want to
make sure that there is no racial
profiling in regards to how they are
actually collecting data so I think
that's a big concern for us how do we
make sure and this is it in connection
to the work that we're doing we've been
doing a lot of work in regards to
collection of data of immigrant youth
who are perceived to be King gang
members who on quote writing so so it's
it's aligned to what we're doing in
making sure that they don't target young
Muslim men who they perceive to be
quote-unquote persons of interest or or
national security threat so I think we
have raised some of those concerns with
law enforcement and I think there needs
to be more oversight and transparency
about how that data is collected
attempts is just within local law
enforcement that that is maintained and
then they'll rely on that for you know
further investigations and I think if
there is probable cause then you know
you know there is that but then when it
comes to some of those programs we have
been very concerned in regards to the
lack of oversight and how that this
question for that office is very vague
and very broad thank you very much
appreciate all of you being here and out
of
adversity sometimes does come
opportunity it's nice to see that you're
all working together and hope that we
can be a resource and that if there
thinks we can do legislatively we will
be able to help and with that we have
our final panel meeting the challenge
and this is perspectives from the field
so we have law enforcement folks here
and really want to close the hearing
today by hearing from those who are
tasked on a day-to-day basis with
meeting this challenge that we are
experiencing and the questions really
are how do we how do you grapple with
ensuring that our public spaces are safe
secure and welcoming for all while fully
upholding the right to free expression
and that includes public expression of
hate so this is a challenge we started
off with professor and Dean Chemerinsky
talking about the fact that speech no
matter how bad it may seem or no matter
how hateful is permissible and it must
be permitted at the same time you also
have responsibilities to make sure that
people in our public safe faces are safe
and secure so what additional supporter
changes do you need from the legislature
to help you accomplish that mission and
I know we'd ask you to start off talking
about how you on the ground actually
meet those balances how do you make
those determinations and then well can
we as a legislature do to assist you
while we combat hate while protecting
constitutional rights of speech so with
that we will start with Andrew Greenwood
who is the chief of police for the city
of Berkeley
you've certainly been in the eye of the
storm and if you'd like to proceed again
if you would for seven minutes and then
we'll hopefully have time for questions
here today
excuse me 10 minutes I've been corrected
so you have 10 minutes each
we have indeed been sort of the eye of
the storm with regards to managing a
dynamic new kind of emerging protest and
First Amendment speech a set of issues
from February 1st of this year when a
University of California event was
disrupted by a coordinated masked
anonymous group of a black-clad
extremists and Tifa in that instance a
large group approached the campus and
immediately set to violence throwing
objects at officers who are on perimeter
security ultimately going on to the
campus disrupting the event causing it
to be canceled and committing acts of
violence amongst others who were there
and ultimately going on to our city
streets sometime after and causing a
significant amount of damage in our
business district that was sort of an
unforeseen event but it was for me
professionally the the emergence of the
issue of of managing a large group or
having to deal with a large group of
Antipa and our policing as a result of
that and the I think the external
driving forces that frame what happened
as a lack of freedom of speech because
the event was cancelled and so forth
Berkeley including our downtown or Civic
Center Park became the locus of
follow-on demonstrations where folks
often external to our community were
arguing essentially that there needs to
be free speech and we're going to come
Express that free speech folks from the
alt-right at the time that we were
considering them and learning about them
and there's a sense that there's some
that's being set out as a challenge and
then we have folks in our community who
who disagree with that speech and are
going to turn out in response to that
and a new thing for us really was how to
police when you have two groups who are
coming together potentially to fight
literally potentially armed with
protective gear padding shields
Bin's who are assembling to do that and
then with with as many if not more
people who are there to observe often
from inches or feet away and video
record or photograph the conflict that
creates a very challenging or created a
very challenging piece for us which is
how do you essentially start going in
with limited resources from our Police
Department we're a medium-sized Police
Department with 160 officers and so
we're not bringing large city scale
resources to that problem and that was
very challenging we are accountable for
every amount of force that we use and to
go essentially break up a fight or to
move in where violence is occurring is
extremely challenging where there's a
lot of folks who aren't actually
involved in it but who may be injured or
be subject to use of force physically as
officers would maybe come in to to stop
violent acts and so it was a challenge
for us on our March 4th event we had
lessons learned we made a 10 I think at
least 10 arrests focused arrests where
we were able to loop back and go after
people that we had seen April 15 saw
another demonstration similar and we had
changed up our strategy and really for
us this is a story of constantly
updating and changing our strategies to
to adjust to this kind of emerging
emerging challenge April 15th we had a
park policy where our manager is able to
strike a one day rule in the park that
says no weapons are allowed you have to
come in through a controlled access
point you can't bring staff so you can't
bring shields and so we used a
controlled access point approach we used
our own resources in terms of officers
which is more in the scores dozens or
scores rather than hundreds and we were
confronted by several dozen anti showing
up on mass reaching the park they were
confronted and set down some of their
larger weapons but the that event that
event turned very challenging as the
groups came together and there were
outbreaks of violence in that in that
day we made over 20 or
and of course lessons learned now as we
approached into our August August 27th
which was another planned rally really
the lessons learned start to coalesce
and to bring us kind of where I want to
share we're at where we're at today
which is that the the strategies that we
look at now is evaluating the the
evaluating who's coming and why it's not
the content of the speech so much as
what the response is going to be and the
size and scope of people are gonna have
to deal with it's been shown really that
the solution essentially is to separate
create a physical separation of space so
that folks from one side or the other
are able to express their speech but in
a way that's physically separate because
our responsibility is really to create
that space where we can to to ensure
their space an opportunity for peaceful
expression of First Amendment speech so
separate now as we found on August 27th
one group essentially didn't show up so
we have a big Civic Center Park we set
up some very hardscaping options and not
options a hard scape with barriers and
plans we also though dialed up our
mutual aid and had more hundreds of
officers from from the area assisting us
then and that even became challenging as
separate demonstrations from around the
city counter demonstrations occurred
prior to the schedule one o'clock they
want to talk event in our Park they
coalesced and marched from different
areas and one of those elements came
with an Tifa sound truck and with antifa
and the truck filled with shields and
there was a confrontation there was a
decision that had to be made rapidly
about do we as a police department use
force to to enforce essentially a
infraction law that coming into the park
that's actually an infraction not even a
misdemeanor to the extent do we enforce
that law and have a giant sort of fight
do we respond to the provocation that's
being placed in front of us and in the
moment we just
at the park which was half empty which
was set up to separate two groups but
one group had not literally had not come
that the best decision was to yield that
space and not have that confrontation
also in great part because the the the
antifoam who were there were are
surrounded and amidst many folks who are
not masked and who are protesting and so
again we get in that issue of force and
potential collateral damage and the
accountability that we have and
responsibility to our community to use
force in a precise and directed way
where needed primarily to affect any
violent crimes that are occurring in
these subsequent events what we found
was by using separation we tried to set
the stage for there to be First
Amendment speech when groups don't show
but instead crowds intermingle which is
what happened with us in late September
on the streets adjacent to University
just a couple of weeks ago our strategy
had to adjust up and that strategy was
to have our people in close amongst the
crowd in full uniform and ready to take
swift action should a violent crime
occur and so that's what we did and we
made several arrests that were really on
that moment to interdict and stop
violence from happening so that proved
to be an effective and effective tactic
we also with our city and we're working
kind of collaboration teamwork with our
city attorney and city staff we created
a an ordinance that allows our city
manager to propagate a rule that on a
specific date and time in a specific
area in our city the implements of riot
may not be carried and to do so as a
misdemeanor and implements of riot would
be a stick assigns shields essentially
weapons you can use in riot it did not
include masks as Dean Chemerinsky
mentioned earlier there is concern and
constitutional issue about masks so just
to clarify that the city rule regarding
conduct on streets and sidewalks did not
include masks but that rule essentially
allowed us to set up a zone around the
University of California
several rocks that excuse me several
blocks out in every direction
where somebody with a shield or with an
implement of riot could be legally
stopped and arrested potentially
detained and so forth we found that that
to be a very effective tool the concern
as I saw was watching live streams of
our events in late September multiple
people commented on the fact that it was
understood no masks were allowed in the
whole area and that that seemed to
reduce the likelihood of violence and
certainly the presence of over presence
of an Tifa so our strategies are
multiple they include separating where
we know there's going to be a group they
include taking swift action also behind
the scenes I really want to point out
that the the February event caused the
University of California police she
understood Mario Bennett and myself on
our organizations to work more closely
together in planning historically in
Berkeley if a problems on campus and
maybe it has resources of mutual aid
then once it goes off campus it feels
like it's now it's Berkeley's problem
and what we've done is really strike a
good working relationship we're using
the the concept of a joint command so
we're running a command center that
includes the highest levels of command
with the Berkeley Police Department the
University of California police
department and are really valued allies
the Alameda County Sheriff's Office the
California Highway Patrol the Oakland
Police Department so the commanders are
working together in the same room
working through solutions to the
problems and we found that that
integrated approach in real time with
essentially sort of shot callers and
commanders together is an effective way
to not only manage the issues that might
face our city or the university but to
handle that transition when activity on
campus now transitions onto our streets
and instead of there being some
formalistic or difficult transfer of
command we are with them the entire time
moving on so those are some of our
lessons learned I think our elements of
success appreciate I'm sure we'll have
questions for you going forward thank
you so much our next witness is Don
theodoro the university counsel for Cal
State University in San Luis Obispo go
Mustangs
good morning right hi good morning madam
chair and committee members can you hear
me yes my name is dawn Theodora I'm a
member of the California State
University office of general counsel and
I am chief campus counsel for Cal Poly
San Luis Obispo I have worked
extensively on First Amendment issues
for the campus and for the system on
behalf of the chancellor's office as
well for the last 16 years we're very
grateful that you are having this
hearing today and want to thank you for
including the CSU in this really
important discussion we are very
thankful for Dean Chemerinsky you can
see I have his book here I had purchased
a case of these books before I knew
about this hearing was asked to come
here and pass them out to my entire
executive cabinet at Cal Poly San Luis
Obispo I believe you know everything you
need to know about what we deal with on
campus with respect to free speech is
set out in this book in an excellent way
sorry he's not here to to hear you plug
for his book I already did that this
morning and he said I made his day I
just needed to get him to sign it and I
missed that opportunity everyone in this
room that you've heard from today is who
we represent at the California State
University students and employees make
up all the people that you're looking at
and that you've been listening to this
morning it breaks my heart as a human
being as a mother a wife a civil rights
attorney to hear the hate that goes on
diversity and inclusion our core values
for California State University these
values drive our efforts to ensure that
all 23 campuses are welcoming and safe
environments for our four hundred and
eighty thousand students our fifty
thousand faculty and staff as well as
the public our first priority and
everything we do is to support the
well-being development safety and
success of our students these important
goals require an inclusive campus
environment where the variety of
backgrounds perspectives and cultures
represented by our students faculty and
staff are
respected embraced and celebrated as you
heard from Dean Chemerinsky as a public
university we also have a responsibility
to uphold free speech and free
expression and provide an open forum for
a variety of opinions thoughts and ideas
including those that may be distasteful
offensive and hateful as a public
institution we cannot engage in
censorship in any form we don't have
so-called limited free speech zones on
our campus our campuses are free speech
zones our entire campus is a free speech
zone and we work we work really hard to
correct miscommunications and
misunderstandings about free speech
rights and responsibilities well we
can't ensure that people's feelings
won't be hurt we can ensure that our
campuses are open forms for everyone to
engage in open dialogue and debate and
express their viewpoints even if if
unpopular and we can and do ensure much
like what you just heard the chief from
Berkeley talked about we ensure that
physical violence and illegal harassment
are not welcome on our campuses our
university campuses are crucibles of
ideas not a cocoon
we can't legislate decorum unfortunately
it is the CSU's responsibility to
support the rights of all people to
express their opinions and ideas it is
in this environment that our students
hone critical thinking skills by
evaluating a spectrum of information and
reaching informed and intelligent
conclusions likewise all students have
the right to participate fully in our
programs and our activities free from
discrimination harassment and a hostile
learning and living environment many of
our campuses are residential campuses we
embrace and encourage our community
differences in age disability gender
identity gender expression marital
status medical condition nationality
race ethnicity religion sexual
orientation and veteran or military
status and other characteristics that
make our community unique enrich our
learning environment and reflect the
diversity of the people the state of
California given our values and our
diversity I will speak to some of CSU's
policies
that provide guidance to this issue some
of the best practices that we employ
much of what we just heard from chief
and some of what we do to appropriately
balance the rights of free expression
while ensuring a welcoming and inclusive
learning and living environment to the
fullest extent possible so we have a
very multifaceted approach to free
speech you've heard a lot today about
time place and manner policies we have
quite robust time place and manner
policies on each of our 23 campuses
these policies all include statements on
free expression we have a system-wide
guidance document in the form of a
general what we call a handbook on free
speech issued by the office of general
counsel of the CSU my office the OGC
continuously works with campuses on free
speech issue issues and activities on a
daily basis there's not a day that goes
by that something doesn't happen on one
of our 23 campuses where the office of
general counsel is in guiding and trying
to help you know our campuses walk that
fine line and do the right things all 23
campuses recently met for a day-long
discussion on all of these issues they
discussed free expression crisis
management and best practices UC is
Howard Gilman who we talked about
earlier this morning attended and shared
his advice and insights during that
discussion we've trained every campus
cabinet as I said I've shared this book
and done a whole lot of other things
we've trained faculty senates and many
others as I'm going to share with you
today education and training is key each
campus has a strategic preparedness task
force or committee in place dedicated to
just these issues to planning and
preparing for all events and free speech
activities so that we can support our
students and employees and planning and
executing successful events and
activities we want to do this to ensure
that these activities are always carried
out in a safe lawful and non disruptive
manner we engage in complex robust
thorough fair and content-neutral event
and activity planning we engage all
stakeholders especially
our students again we engage in
education I call it training training
and more training tailored for campus
audiences for student groups for
divisions for student government for
employee groups for faculty for faculty
senates and we also engage in our local
cities and communities we go to human
relations commissions meetings like I
did recently in San Luis Obispo and
provide a fulsome training on what free
speech is and what free speech is not
and we engage them in that conversation
because we do need their help we do need
their mutual aid to help us do what we
do on campus we infuse our University
programs and academics with the tenets
and principles of free speech academic
freedom and inclusive excellence we have
constant conversations and dialogue on
our campuses by creating space for
communication and outreach where
everyone feels welcome and included so
they feel a sense of community
empowerment ownership and belonging we
plan many events throughout the academic
year that celebrate free speech
diversity and inclusion so that we are
intentional and not reactionary what I
mean by that is that we plan events and
activities throughout the year
we know that students and employees are
more likely to feel a sense of community
and belonging so that when and if
something happens and it always does
they know they are welcomed and valued
before the bad thing happens we plan for
intergroup communication we plan this
allows for small groups to get together
to discuss how they feel as I mentioned
we prohibit of course discrimination of
any kind including unlawful harassment
that misconduct violates our policy and
violate state and federal laws I'm not
going to go into too many details about
our our policies because you heard a lot
about that from Dean Chemerinsky but I
also wanted to mention that with respect
to our time place and manner policies we
are constantly updating them we were
revising them and they are a
comprehensive set of policies to deal
with these issues and the main reason we
are updating and revising all the time
is because things are have happened
on a constant basis and the laws are
changing quickly our policies set forth
the standards for what constitutes the
illegal harassment which is a fine line
and you heard a lot about that from Dean
Chemerinsky however speech that merely
expresses offensive views toward a
protected protected class or is rude
discourteous or teasing as you heard
does not rise to the level of illegal or
impermissible harassment that affects a
student's ability to enjoy the
educational opportunities and benefits
having said that most of the time of a
specific incident of what most people
would consider harassment does not rise
to the level of impermissible allele
harassment we still have people with
legitimate feelings of being targeted
and marginalized and disrespected and
it's in that space where we as an
institution try to help by engaging in
the resources engaging in some of the
things that we do our primary goal again
is to ensure that everyone feels
welcomed and safe if you could wrap it
up I will thank you so I wanted to talk
a little bit about what Cal Poly did
with respect to a couple of recent
incidents including a recent visit by
Maya innopolis I think a day or two
before he appeared at Berkeley back in
January February timeframe I was happy
to hear that the chief just describes
some of the things that we engaged in to
keep the campus safe one of the most
important things I thought we did in
that situation in addition to the buffer
zones and the controlled access points
and all the things that our law
enforcement do to keep us safe is that
we planned a concurrent event called
inclusion starts with me
that was a unite Cal Poly week-long
event it was a celebration that included
open forums daily faculty lectures
culture exchanges performances
entertainment you name it and it was
addressing speech with speech so while
everybody was preparing for Milo to come
to campus which we were able to
successfully implement without incident
we were also engaging encounters
and those are the types of things that
we need to be doing on campuses those
are the resources that we need to be
able to address the types of issues in
just a small way that we've been hearing
about today thank you very much and I'm
hopeful that we'll have a chance to get
more in questions if not if you would
make sure that you provide us with the
full comments if you would like thank
you so much our next speaker is Warren
Stanley acting commissioner Warren
Stanley with the California Highway
Patrol so we're delighted as always to
see you and very interested in hearing
what you have to share with us today
thank you sir thank you madam chair and
committee members as stated on warrants
and lead acting commissioner of the
California Highway Patrol and the CHP we
strive to protect the First Amendment
rights of those involved in
demonstrations while ensuring the safety
of all participants and spectators and
we appreciate the opportunity to come
here and have this important discussion
with you and also want to thank your
staff for their support and overarching
concern of this committee is to avoid
the violence that occurred recently in
Charlottesville Virginia this is a
concern we share and is a challenge for
the CHP and all law enforcement agencies
across the nation as you aware our civil
demonstrations are not static events
they evolve they grow and sometimes they
attract violent elements that directly
disrupt the rights of peaceful
demonstrators and it can be a complex
balancing act to preserve those First
Amendment rights while maintaining peace
and ensuring public safety I would like
to begin by discussing a few
jurisdictional roles that we play in
civil demonstrations depending on where
they occur I will then briefly describe
how we train our personnel in response
to these events and civil demonstrations
and then we'll provide some examples of
our efforts at recent events to
illustrate how we deploy and manage the
resources and then the last part we'll
get to assistant commissioner syllabic
Silsbee will talk about the discussion
about how we handle events here at the
Capitol we'll describe our permit
process
for providing access to space here at
this Capitol and other state facilities
and describe how we manage those events
also the CHP has a direct role in
responding to civil demonstrations
occurring here at the State Capitol and
other state property including freeways
and highways
the CHP we also provide assistance as
the chief talked about a few minutes ago
to our allied agency partners and when
they also need assistance regards to
civil demonstrations in talking about
state property our primary role the
California Vehicle Code provides that
the CHP has a primary jurisdictional
responsibility over incidents occurring
on freeways state highways and
unincorporated roadways now in 1995 when
the state police was merged with the
California Highway Patrol we then took
over primary jurisdictional
responsibilities over all incidents
including civil demonstrations which
occur on state property other than
property under the jurisdiction of
another state law enforcement agency
like for example state parks if an
incident occurs here at the Capitol or
on the freeway for instance the CHP has
direct oversight over the law
enforcement response and will be the
incident commander in regards to helping
our local partners local police and
sheriff's departments they have primary
jurisdiction or responsibility over
civil demonstrations that occur and
locations that are now state property
however has been discussed by the chief
there are times when these agencies they
don't have enough resources and they
reach out to us and other law
enforcement agencies to provide
assistance in those cases the CHP will
respond to support local agencies during
emergency incidents relating to civil
demonstration or other unusual
occurrences after their chase their
resources and adjacent resources have
been committed
this requires Commissioner approval
before before formally committing these
resources however our division and area
commanders do have the authority to
start
mobilizing personnel for example during
the recent protests in Berkeley we
assisted them with the protests there if
the combined resources of neighboring
law enforcement agencies and the CHP are
not sufficient additional assistance can
be requested through the regional law
force of mutual aid coordinator now
California is divided into seven regions
each of which has a designated County
Sheriff who is the coordinator for a law
force of mutuality requests the regional
coordinator is responsible for making
formal requests for assistance for law
enforcement agencies including the CHP
if the resources from that region aren't
inefficient they're not enough then the
office of emergency services law
enforcement division will coordinate
requests from throughout the state I'm
going to talk about training for a few
moments and training and preparation
like the chief talked about is very
vital to any civil demonstration because
we want to protect the rights of free
speech but we also want to maintain
public safety and during academy
training all of our CHP cadets they get
eight hours of civil disturbance
training they also get four hours of
tactical right training while they're in
the academy and then annually are all of
our personnel receive in-service
training on tactical formations tactical
communications and crowd control
techniques now several years ago we put
together what we call Special Response
Teams so these teams are made up of
individuals who have provided additional
training these teams are combined of
officers who are specially trained and
equipped who can respond rapidly to
civil disturbance and other incidents or
emergencies throughout the state one of
these specialized teams is located in
each of our eight field divisions that
we have throughout the state and these
officers receive a lot more training
these officers receive 20 hours of
initial certification training then they
receive
an additional 16 hours of annual
recertification training and then on a
quarterly basis they received eight
hours of refresher training and the
members of these teams are selected
based largely on their experience and
their maturity in handling complex
incidents and demonstrations I want to
talk a few minutes about our response to
recent events and where we responded
both in a primary role in a support role
in the last year in fact last week we
responded to the University of
California and assisted the University
of California Berkeley Police Department
and Berkeley with the free-speech weeds
week that they have err recently
following the president presidential
election to CHP provided emergency
response to several spontaneous
unplanned civil demonstrations in the
San Francisco Bay Area and in the LA
area and in those demonstrations we have
we played both roles some are our
responsibilities were a primary role of
keeping our freeways open and
safeguarding state property and in a
support role of supporting our local law
enforcement agencies and then in 2016 I
don't know if you're aware approximately
300 CHP officers we responded to
Cleveland Ohio in a response for
assistance to assist at the Republican
National Convention and myself and
assistant commissioner Sylvie Silsbee we
took 290 CHP officers to Cleveland Ohio
to assists with the Republican National
Convention and also there are other
state law enforcement agencies from
throughout the United States that the
city of Cleveland and Iowa State Police
have requested provide assistance at the
Republican National Convention and I
want to finish up by getting to the
permitting process and an assistant
commissioner Silsbee will jump into that
but we all understand that the CHP as as
the center of California government the
state capital in the capital Park or
preferred location for groups to whole
civil demonstrations on
a wide spectrum of political and social
issues the CHP is highly sensitive to
the importance of this location and
ensuring that groups have an outlet here
for peaceful free speech events
Assistant Commissioner Silsbee who
oversees our field operations will take
a couple minutes outlining both our
permit processes for events here at the
Capitol and some of the things that we
take in consideration when planning and
responding to these events so I'll turn
it over to you thank you very much and
so delighted to have Scot Silsbee who is
the assistant commissioner with the
California Highway Patrol here to talk
about some of these issues good good
morning sir
thank you madam chair members it's not
lost on me that I'm last so recognize
you're busy so the government code the
California Government Code gives the
California or all the authority to make
rules and regulations on state property
and specifically Capitol grounds the
California Code of regulations style 13
is where we define the permit process
and essentially for us the permit
process is that it requires a 10-day
advance notice you have to get it in
writing and we have an online process it
makes it very easy for folks to do that
and go on and see a calendar and find
out when you'd like to go from there
once that application process is started
we have a permit officer here at the
Capitol who basically vets that group
and they do a little background they
basically look to make sure that they're
being truthful that they're who they say
they are they want to know what their
cause is and from there the intelligence
gathering goes a little deeper primarily
it's open source online information so
as you can imagine we have a case
Support Unit and a threat assessment
unit who will go deeper into finding out
you know what what may be out there on
the group and frankly anymore it's not
so much the group it's the counter a
counter-protest activity that we're a
little more concerned with these days as
chief Greenwood specified so as we look
into that with our own resources if the
threat looks a little higher we'll check
with our allied agency resources the
fusion center is potentially the Joint
Terrorism Task Force typically the
information we find is duplicative we
all have the same stuff that we want to
check all those bases right so denials
here at the Capitol we get about 1200
permits a year
we deny then I'll use finger quotes deny
about 200 a year and typically very very
few of those are for public safety
reasons usually it's administrative
folks don't realize it they're camping
and commercial activity they can't have
a bake sale they don't realize that the
permits go to dgs the department general
services and they determine whether
insurance is needed and that could be a
game-changer for a group also security
for every 50 people that you bring
you've got to have one person at least
for security and that could be cost
prohibitive for a group also look at
their history have they been a problem
before if they followed the rules but as
I said very rarely in fact zero in 2016
were for public safety 2017 we have one
that was for public safety and I'll tell
you a little bit about it basically it
was a group called make America great
again you may have heard of it there
were a group that was working with us
organizer was very upfront a couple
hundred folks were planning on coming
ultimately is our background that we
looked into it we found out that they
were telling their folks hey you need to
bring Tasers and pepper spray to protect
yourself and we had the same response
and then looking further we realized
that the reason and that this is what
they told us was they were hearing from
other online sources that the other side
of the argument was saying bring pepper
spray and bring weapons so didn't matter
to us they had espoused bringing weapons
under the capital so we denied that
which saved us all a lot of trouble let
me tell you a little bit about some of
the cases that we've had here a little
history and I think you'll see a theme
because things escalate as far as what
certain groups are willing to do so in
2011 there's a group called the South
South Africa project and their cause was
white genocide in South Africa again our
cause is here at the Highway Patrol is
to allows the free expression of First
Amendment rights so we didn't see
anything that cost us too much concern
is a very small group we made
arrangements with them it was under 20
people we made arrangements as we often
do because we found that the key to
these is being involved with the
organizer and having an open dialogue
and trust in the relationship so we
orchestrated that when they arrived
they would arrive at the north side and
a parking structure where we would
escort them to the steps where they
would be allowed to demonstrate for the
for the length of their permit and we
were when they left we would escort them
out as is typical of these type of
groups there's about three times as many
counter protesters there and the counter
protesters were doing their thing but
weren't overly aggressive as they
started as we started to wrap it up they
started to wrap it up and we were
starting to prepare to escort them out
that fort a group of 40 who is who later
self identified themselves as an tyfa
dropped their backpacks that they were
carrying around pulled out black hoods
masks and pulled out rocks and concrete
and started for lack of a better term to
attack the South Africa South Africa
project have been a bit of a melee to
CHP officers were injured some folks
were arrested and then you know we we
cleared everything out later in 2011 a
couple examples for you later in 2011 I
think you'll recall there was a group of
student protesters that came to the
building and they were protesting budget
issues within the UC and the university
system they worked with us very closely
very well and as you can imagine they
had a statement they wanted to make
ultimately they wanted to get into the
capital they wanted to take over the
Rotunda and have a sit-in typically
that's not something we don't want a
disruption in government services but
we're flexible enough we worked with
them they went in we did our thing
dispersal order gave them more time
given the opportunity for all the media
to capture it and ultimately it went
down then next year something different
happened started with and this is not
unusual but this that year the following
year they wanted to have two people
arrested okay not unusual they want to
have their cause carried out somebody
getting arrested makes that case they
worked with us very closely and as much
as it may have looked like the CSP was
the big bad guy it was all orchestrated
when we arrested them and it worked out
well everybody was fine but as we were
arresting them once again another group
dropped their backpacks masked up put on
black hoods and started causing damage
inside the capital we ended up having to
we had our Special Response Team which
commissioner Stanley mentioned off-site
but close by they ended up having to
come in a group of about 70 or 80 riot
law enforcement to to quell it so that
the last one I'll give you is one they
are all very familiar with that happened
on June 26 where the traditionalist
Workers Party which is a well-known
white supremacist group had applied for
an application very smug now it's well
known but there's a very small group
less than 20 people they had put the per
minute we've never had any problems with
them before so I say okay we're gonna
lie to come in after we approved the
permit we start trying to work with them
so we could do the same thing that we
had done with the SA P group which is to
escort them in and get them to the point
and then get them back out well they
never responded we left messages we had
done emails and frankly hindsight we
should have cancelled the permit because
they weren't responding to us we just
assumed that they would show up where we
had directed them to so we had several
dozen officers out there waiting there
was some you know upwards of 150 to 200
early on protesters ranging from family
members to to a little more anarchist
looking folks that were out there
looking back we started to realize and
looking at video as as we were looking
at prosecution there was people walking
around with signs that were signs but
they had two-by-fours that were there
that we're holding the sign and that's a
violation sorry and there were also we
found video of a truck that pulled up
that and that unloaded about eight to
ten pairs of crutches and I didn't
remember seeing a lot of people walking
around that were you know that needed
crutches later to be used as weapons
so I digress as we were waiting they the
the ante folks and the BAM folks had
better spotters than we did and they
spotted that the twelve to twenty folks
from Twp were coming from the extreme
southeast side complete opposite from
where we were and where most of our
resources were before we were even aware
they messaged each other they dropped
their backpacks they mashed up but the
hoodies on pulled their rocks and
concrete and balloons full of what was a
pepper spray like substance and they
sprinted around the capital towards
where those twelve to twenty folks were
and had it obviously as we're all aware
now they had a big conflict and a
was a running gang fight by the time we
could get almost 200 between Sac City
police and us over there there was 14
injuries and I'll admit is very
embarrassing the reality of that day was
14 people were injured there was
thousands of dollars of damage to the
capital and while we sought prosecution
after a very lengthy investigation for
106 people the DA understandably said
you know this is mutual combat in most
these cases but we had four cases two on
each side or felony assault with a
deadly deadly weapon and inciting a riot
Wow warrants were issued and they were
affected within the last couple months
so what did we learn from that frankly
it was a tough one because how do you
how do you really stop a hundred-plus
overly aggressive folks who are
unpermitted who are willing to sprint
towards another much smaller group to
effect violence the way you do it is as
the chief talked about control points
which are always hard control points
were always difficult here at the
Capitol and the Capitol grounds is 40
acres right this is the people's house
we want people to be able to come here
the people's Park we want them to be
come here and express their First
Amendment rights the other thing is huge
numbers of law enforcement right so we
could have had 40 acres of this park we
could have had several hundred officers
in riot gear arm and arm probably being
the only way to stop that and that would
have costs as everybody has talked about
a great great deal of money for one of
our teams is about 70 people and for a
one full shift of 70 to 80 of our SRT
officers about $80,000 so the the cost
of that is very real
so trying to also the other problem with
that is it's a police state right not
only is it costly but now you have you
have a police do you have right cops
everywhere and we have learned from the
past that that's really not something
that's appreciated understandably here
at the Capitol thank you for your
testimony this this discussion will
continue with the next hearing
I am confident on this whole issue of
how we address you know when people want
to get to get
and hurt each other they they tend to do
that and so those are questions that we
need to have answered for sure we
promised a public comment of 15 minutes
I'm going to keep to that and as a
result if you have I do have questions I
think many of us do but I did commit to
a 15-minute public comment period so
would you give your if there are
additional comments that you have that
you would like to provide we would love
to include them in our final document
and do appreciate what you're doing
there's a kind of a constant set of
themes here and hopefully we will emerge
with some good solutions on how to
address these problems so thank you all
very much for your testimony thank you
[Music]
so at this point in time we've got about
it's 12:20 I know that I did agree mr.
Shapiro will let you be our first
speaker
are there other public speakers people
who want to speak as well if you would
go follow mr. Shapiro's at the
microphone others who wish to speak two
minutes each and then we will close and
we might actually get done by 12:30
which I would appreciate so mr. Shapiro
your name has come up a few times before
today I didn't know who you were before
I heard from mr. Morlock nice to meet
you and as well the floor is yours
and I would like just to ask you don't
have to because this is free speech time
the the subject matter is combating hate
while protecting the Constitution and if
you have a couple minutes worth of ideas
on that that would be great if you'd
rather not talk in that that's okay too
but no really happy thank you well I
appreciate the 120 seconds so I your job
obviously here at the legislature is to
ensure that our freedom of expression is
maintained that our First Amendment
rights are maintained and what that
means first and foremost in my
experiences on college campuses is that
the hecklers veto must be
stopped so I was at Cal State Los
Angeles in February 2016 and there was
almost a riot there and the police were
not allowed to do their jobs and
students were physically assaulted in
the crowd it is the job of this
legislature to ensure the police can do
their jobs and when they do do their
jobs and they're allowed to do that a
places like UC Berkeley everything goes
fine and I'd like to make a point here
about UC Berkeley the reason it cost
$600,000 to bring me to UC Berkeley was
not because of me
okay everybody keeps suggesting that it
was because I was coming I'm so
controversial and so terrible I came
exactly one year before and it costed
this many dollars it cost zero dollars
for security at UC Berkeley the reason
it cost $600,000 at UC Berkeley is
because an Tifa and violent groups had
decided that Berkeley was their domain
and they were going to be able to run
roughshod over law enforcement there and
this does bring up one final point that
I want to make in the long period of
time that I have to discuss and that is
the problem with a legislative bodies
such as yours trying to draw a line
specifically about what hate speech
constitutes because the fact is that one
of the reasons groups like antiva show
up is not because they know who I am
it's because they have been told by
people that I am promulgating hate
speech which is utterly false and
utterly untrue there are people who say
vile things and with him I disagree
among them people like milo gianopolous
who sent me a picture of a black baby on
the day of my child's birth because I
wasn't sufficiently standing up for the
white population supposedly but that
does not mean that the legislature gets
to decide what hate speech is I've been
labeled to promulgator of hate speech
when I was the number one target of hate
speech according to the ADL among the
journalistic community in 2016 so let me
suggest that as a legislature your chief
job is to ensure that my tax payer
dollars in this state go toward making
sure that people like me and people with
who might disagree you get to speak in
places like college campuses and not
toward regulating what speech you find
good and what speech you find bad
because it's a really dangerous business
and their speech I don't like if their
speech you don't like but if we can't
agree that there is a difference between
speech and violence we're not gonna be
able to have a free state let alone a
free country thanks thank you much
appreciated I think what I think we all
agree with you good all right thank you
next witness if you give us if you'd
like to give us your name and
affiliation sir absolutely
Mario Guerrero on behalf of the
California Faculty Association the CFA
is committed to protecting academic
freedom including the right
of faculty students and staff to engage
in debate and public protests protests
after all of the oldest form of civic
engagement in fact many of our CSU
faculty staff and students engage in
peaceful protests all the time as
members of the university communities we
believe deeply in the free exchange of
ideas because the prop that process
engages our minds teaches as judgment
and helps us achieve wisdom these values
and practices are critical today when
more diverse when with when a more
diverse California population finds
itself in a more diverse CSU which we
call the people's University hate speech
unfortunately has the opposite effect it
silences our voices and deliberately
excludes both specific members and
entire groups from debate hate speech
shuts down discussion hate speech does
not search for wisdom or even make an or
even to make an argument but rather
shout shouts invective
and creates a narrative designed to
intimidate others CFA stands against
white supremacy racism and hate speech
we will support and defend all of our
members on campus communities from
racist sexist nationalist homophobic
transphobic anti-muslim and anti-semitic
attacks we condemn all hate speech and
hate crimes on campus and in our
surrounding communities CFA will
continue to fight for the rights of
campus communities to remain peaceful
and just we will not back down for
protecting faculty staff and students
and defending the values of our
university system which is among the
best in the nation
the CSU administration has the moral
obligation to condemn hate speech every
single time it happens and to act
swiftly to protect the safety of
students faculty and staff we encourage
the CSU administration to treat hate
speech and expressions as active
violence that threaten both our academic
pursuits and our community a free
inquiry thank you very much are there
any other individuals who would like to
step forward for two minutes
public comment all right we are we are
just we are on time I want to thank
everybody for being here I want to thank
my colleagues who attended this this
hearing in
and before we close would anybody like
to the say a final word
senator Moreland thank you madam chair
and thanks for the discussion like I
said at the beginning it maybe just
boils down to good manners that we
should learn to agree disagree we might
disagree what we should disagree
agreeably and so a lot of this stuff is
good debate we have it on the Senate
floor we have it in committee but we do
have certain groups that are coming on
campuses that we have to deal with and
we have to figure out how to help our
public safety officials but we also have
to help the students I did a bill this
year madam chair you know that you had
fun with in judiciary on whistleblowing
students who are you know being maybe a
victim of hate speech because some
instructors don't like certain you know
individuals and it just kind of flows
all over the place so we we all have
some improvement we can make and I
appreciate your doing this hearing so
you have a time of reflection thank you
thank you well I want to thank everyone
who was here you know this is this very
tricky issue free speech and
understanding that some people feel that
hate speech is destructive I would tend
to agree but the Supreme Court I think
has made it very clear and so certainly
we will continue to disagree I hope we
will do it respectfully I hope that all
of our discussions will be respectful
and that we respect each other now
people will be treated with dignity and
appreciation for a common humanity we've
had some some points of contention
during the hearing as to who is doing
what to whom but I think it was very
clear that the more we can educate and
expose each other to different ideas and
to different points of views and to
different cultures and that which makes
such a unique place to be the United
States being the melting pot of the
world with all our different cultures
and life experiences which really I
think are what enrich us and knowing
that hate and intolerance do indeed
undermine our common humanity regardless
of who expresses it I think that's I
think critically important that we we
have to do better
and so I want to thank my staff and all
those who are here and particularly Tim
Griffiths who's been working his
proverbial backside off to help make
this I think a very meaningful
discussion but I think we heard strong
and bipartisan support for two
fundamental points first that that hate
and intolerance do indeed impact us as
human beings and that we I think we all
aspire to do better and should it aspire
to do that or better but as hard as it
can be to swallow the constitutional
right of free speech includes the right
to engage in hate speech and what may be
perceived as hate speech by one may not
be to another but there are certain
things I think that we can all agree are
designed to degrade and manipulate and
dehumanize and subordinate others and
that is not okay but it is also not okay
to try to heckle down a speaker if you
disagree with this point of view and I
share that concern and appreciate mr.
Shapiro sharing that experience with us
so the question then becomes what do we
do with about this and that will be
we'll be thinking about it perhaps
introducing some legislation I think
education is always the key you know
when you sit down with someone and you
find out that there you have more in
common than you have differences well we
all are basic human me needs desires
expectations wants goals and when we
come to understand that I think that we
are all better for it and hopefully
through some legislation going forward
and and encouraging that education and
interactions that we will accomplish the
goals that we all strive for so with
that I want to again thank staff and Tim
for your great work we are adjourned